the fastest way to achieve your goals is
to model the people who've already
achieved the same goals that you have a
lot of success success excludes the
famous expression and it's true people
have already figured out the thing that
you are struggling to figure out and the
more you are stuck trying to come up
with every idea yourself the harder
you're making it on yourself and this is
one of the two fundamental lessons that
I have learned in my life that have
saved my life and my business my first
company I learned this lesson first when
I was 20 years old out of desperation
where I was making no money and
struggling and I quit on my business
partner I modeled Bill Gates I just
asked myself who has done this before
but it's important because that was the
thing that saved me that's that's what
saved my company you know in modeling
Bill Gates and how we started Microsoft
that's what saved my business and
allowed me to keep going and that idea
came to me at a moment of desperation
it's not even the smartest idea right I
mean I wasn't into personal development
I wasn't reading books I didn't I didn't
know anything I didn't want to fail but
I felt there was no option I just felt
overwhelmed frustrated it just was not
working out in every everything felt
lost and it was only in that absolute
moment of Crisis that I thought maybe
somebody else has done this before need
motivation watch a top 10 would believe
Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael and we
made these videos probably because
you're the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
much more and you need that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
my husband Evan Carmichael and our take
on his top 10 rules for Success enjoy
we're up until that point I felt like I
had to come up with every idea myself
like oh maybe we should do this maybe we
should do that maybe we could try this
and nothing would seem to be working and
it wasn't until I asked that question
then I found Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft and that's what
started turning the company around
whatever problem you're facing right now
it's been addressed many many many many
times by many many many many many many
successful people
your job becomes to find out who they
are and to go back and study how they
how they solve that problem and it's
really important to figure out how they
solve the exact problem that you're
struggling with right now so what I told
myself when I was looking at Bill Gates
was
I don't care how Bill Gates makes an
extra million dollars right now how did
he get started how do you go from zero
to one what was the thing that that
built this company up and for all these
people the bigger they are the easier it
is to research their story Bill Gates
only came to mind because I had a
software company and I just said who's
built a software company it was not
even that structured or thought out or
in depth or or you know in detail
he was the first guy that I thought of
that had a software company Bill Gates
Microsoft how do you do it that was it
and in looking at a story I found out
that Microsoft built their business
through Partnerships
and their big deal came when they made a
partnership with IBM in IBM at the time
was the biggest computer manufacturer on
the planet so the deal was every IBM
that was shipped every computer that was
shipped from the biggest computer
manufacturer in the world had Microsoft
software on it it was a huge deal that
blew up the company and that was pretty
easy to find right the transitional
moment in the company
it's like wow okay Partnerships that's
interesting I mean we can do that but
Microsoft was already a seven million
dollar company when they made that deal
now 7 million was nothing compared to
what they would go on to be right
billions and billions of dollars but
it was seven million dollars it was
still more than what I had
right seven million dollars felt like a
giant company compared to me making 300
bucks a month right so the next layer is
to dig a Little Deeper
not just that their big break which is
important but how do they get started
like how did they get to The Big Break
is really valuable it's really helpful
to figure out and again the bigger the
person is that you're modeling the
easier it is to find the content you
just might have to dig you might have to
go read biographies read articles read
interviews watch videos to figure out
those early Parts not their just their
upbringing but what were the things that
they did that led to the big
breakthrough not just what the big
breakthrough was big breakthrough super
important but the steps that led to the
brick big breakthrough even more
important if you're at the beginning
getting started so Microsoft big
breakthrough was the IBM deal they're
already seven million dollar company how
did they get to become a seven million
dollar company that was the million
dollar question maybe the seven million
dollar question and it was still through
Partnerships
so what Microsoft did was they had
software and they looked at any hardware
that existed
that needed software for it
and they would go in and Pitch their
software their first deal was with the
mitz Altair and
uh the mid-tal tear was a was a piece of
hardware and it was featured on the
cover of uh of their magazine that was
the big magazine for the computer
industry at the time and they needed
software and Bill Gates and uh called
them up with his partner Paul Allen and
said hey we've got software for the mid
tall tear that you can use that will
make it a lot more valuable valuable to
people and they didn't even have it
built yet
on the on the on the plane ride over to
go meet the company Bill Gates was
finishing up the code to go program and
they hope that it would work and luckily
it did when they when they had the
meeting uh so I don't I don't
necessarily like that part of lying that
you've got something but it's
interesting to know how he did it that
the boldness the the willingness to
reach out and say hey I've got something
that can help you we're things that I
really struggled with as a 19 year old
entrepreneur believing that what I had
was great then I could really solve big
problems where Bill Gates was saying
yeah we got this even though he didn't
have it yet and he wrote it on the plane
on the on the way over right but it was
still through Partnerships and anytime
Microsoft was entering something new
they found Partnerships and so I applied
that strategy to me and I started
looking for who can who can we partner
with not like a business partner where
they own a piece of our company but who
can we partner with that is a
distribution deal
and the first uh company that I
made a deal with was out of the UK and
we had a arrangement for them to
represent us in the UK in a couple of
the markets in Europe where they would
be Distributing our product and we made
an exclusive deal so that anytime we got
a lead from those markets it would go to
them and they would be doing their own
marketing promotion as well and in
exchange for that exclusive partnership
they would pay us thirteen and a half
thousand dollars up front
and I remember I was I was so scared to
ask for that it felt like a giant number
what if they said no this big potential
deal and uh and they said yes they said
yes and we had we had money in our bank
account for the first time which was
wild and crazy and
that was a fantastic deal for us and
more important is it it said it gave us
hope which is maybe important to give us
momentum which is Mega important and it
gave us a model to keep following and so
what I what I ended up doing after which
was let's go get more partnership deals
let's go get more partnership deals and
the people who ended up buying us was
basically a partnership deal so instead
of partnering with our company they just
bought the whole business
and that's how we exited all because of
modeling Bill Gates when I quit on my
company so whatever
problem you're facing personal or
business people have solved it humans
have been around for a long time
somebody has solved this problem you do
not have to be a genius and come up with
every new idea yourself can your
creativity and love and Panache help yes
of course
but you don't have to have the seed for
every great idea and chances are
the problem that you're facing right now
there's an answer
10 minutes away from you from a YouTube
video that's that's online from a book
from a podcast from an interview there's
an answer out there for you and if you
just default to say I'm going to model
success I'm going to find the people
who've done this and exactly how they
solve that specific problem that you're
facing right now not how they're living
their life right now but how did they
get over the hurdle that you're facing
when you can dig deep and find those
answers and again the bigger the person
is
the more accessible the content is if
you want to learn about Bill Gates's
early life or Steve Jobs early life or
Oprah Winfrey's early life or whoever it
is it's accessible it's there you can
find this stuff
and it gives you the hope
that it's possible for you and it gives
you the specific strategies that you can
use to apply to your life right now so
you can start seeing results
success leaves Clues
whatever problem you've got
gold model success Rule Number Two start
for free the free leads you to the paid
if you have no momentum no traction no
clients then start for free prove your
worth and build momentum give them
something they can't wait to have again
and pay for this time the goal isn't to
do free forever but the free gives you
the thing that you're missing the most
which is momentum in your business so
I'm pre-launching my book right now
built to serve and people who buy the
book and pre-order also get access to my
private Facebook group where I help
people one-on-one every week and so the
guy that I had on last week is a coach
he's a health coach he wants to help
people make transformations to their
health because he made a radical shift
in his health as well and I said great
well how are you doing right now well I
have a couple clients but I'm still
working at a restaurant I want to be
able to leave that so I can focus on
this full-time awesome if you're a coach
what I need to see you is coaching I
need to see you coaching people what I'd
love to see now is an Instagram live
regular show and what do you do on your
Instagram live you bring on people who
need help being coached through a health
transformation because it's one thing to
say I'm a coach and I help people get
these results it's another though to
actually see people change to have you
go live with them one-on-one and help
them bust through their limiting beliefs
and their mindset and the issues that
they're dealing with and then they come
out on the other side by the end of the
call feeling hope feeling invigorated
feeling inspired because people will
watch that and say man
I want a result like that they see
themselves in the client that you're
helping and they then want it for
themselves now you get two versions one
will be free people
one would be like can you do me I I'll
take it for free
which is great don't say no don't get
discouraged don't get upset you want the
free because the free gives you the
content and so if they're willing to
come on and do live on Instagram with
you for free then you do it
and there'll be other people who say hey
I love what you're doing I need a
radical transformation in my health as
well but I don't want to be on Instagram
I don't want to make it public can I can
I hire you privately
Bingo right that's what we're looking
for that's when you start getting paid
the free leech to the paid whatever it
is that you want to get known for
whatever it is you want to start making
money with show it to me publicly for
free and if other people want it
publicly for free as well then it's a
yes especially at the beginning when you
have no momentum and no clients and
you're working some job that you hate
yes for free yes one you get better at
it because the more you do the better
you'll get and two You're Building
momentum and people start talking about
you
and then you get the people who will see
it and say I want that person I want to
I want to hire that person and any
repeat people they want more they want
coaching session number two it's paid
here's how much it costs the free leads
you to the paid so how can you do it I'm
going to give you a three-step process
that you can follow step number one is
think who can you help who specifically
can you help like who are the people
that you want to help so for me it'd be
entrepreneurs if you are a makeup artist
and you're just doing it for yourself or
you have some job that you hate and you
have no no aspiration of being an
entrepreneur I I might be able to help
you a little bit but it's not my core
audience I want to help entrepreneurs
who are the people specifically that you
want to be helping so in the case of the
guy who was in my Insider's group he
started off yesterday and he was a
transformational coach okay great but
that's that could be anything a
transformation everybody needs a
transformation everybody the whole world
needs a transformational coach who
because if you can't tell me exactly who
it is that you helped then I can't I
can't think of who I can refer you to
you're making it too difficult on people
if you serve everybody then you serve
nobody so who are you helping he's like
well I love helping people who need a
big transformational change in their
health because that was me awesome now
it's more specific step number two is
what specifically will you do how do you
help are you gonna are you gonna coach
me through a process you're gonna
meditate with me you're going to give me
you know a product that that will help
me what specifically will you do and so
with my friend who was in the group he
was saying that he he wants to do
coaching calls he coaches people they
don't have to be face to face it can be
anywhere in the world as long as he can
see them right so that's specifically
what you do you have your methodology
you have your steps makes you seem like
an expert and you kind of know what
you're doing right you create your own
methodology say here is how I can help
people get a result from the problem
that they're coming in with and in Step
number three is think how can you make
it public you need them to get a result
you need this specific person with this
problem to come in you're going to help
them you're going to help them get a
result and I want to see them get a
result and then how can you make it
public so that other people can see it
too so that it's not just you talking
about how you had this great result but
it's them in a public forum so I can if
I see them getting a result I'm going to
think I'm just like that person too
I want to contact you and hire you and
bring you on board my team because I
want for me what you just did to that
person so who can you help what
specifically can you do and then how can
you make it public rule number three
keep your mind present eighty percent of
our inner dialogue is negative and 95 of
those thoughts are the same thoughts
that we had yesterday that's what Beth
Handel taught me she's garyvee's life
coach we had an awesome session together
and it really hit home imagine that 80
percent of the thoughts that you've got
eighty percent
are negative we are beating ourselves up
we are telling ourselves that we can't
do things it's not even our friends and
family people around us telling us that
we suck it's us it's ourselves we tell
ourselves we're not good enough we can't
do this we're not strong enough smart
enough we're from the wrong country we
look the wrong way you know we're too
young we're too old whatever it is 80 of
our thoughts are negative and then 95 of
those negative thoughts are the exact
same negative thoughts that we had
yesterday it's no wonder why we stay
small it's no wonder why we stay stuck
because we've created this reinforcing
Loop of negativity this is why I think
the world's biggest problem is lack of
belief I'm on a mission every day wake
up try to make content try to spread the
message to help people believe in
themselves more I think lack of belief
is the single biggest problem in the
world
and I also believe that everybody has
Michael Jordan level genius at something
like you are the greatest you're the
greatest in the world at something and
it's not what you went to school for and
it's not what your parents did for a
living probably it's something
completely different and you have to
have the courage to go off and Chase it
and find it and and do it because
the woman who solves cancer should have
already solved it by now but she never
believed in herself enough to go to
medical school and now she's a manager
and accounting firm which doesn't like
her life right I mean this is this is
where most of us are stuck most people
wake up and they drive their job that
that we don't like most people are stuck
and barely hanging on and do not like
their life and feel like they're not
contributing they're not they're not
making any kind of difference they're
not doing anything meaningful or
impactful at all in the world that's
most people imagine waking up and that's
your daily reality that may be you
or that may have been who you were you
still describe it and try to improve and
get better but if 80 of those thoughts
that come through your head conscious or
unconscious are negative I think a lot
of conscious thoughts are negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative you telling
yourself that you can't do something and
you're not good enough and then 95 are
the same as yesterday that we've just
created this this Loop this this
negative thinking Loop
so how do we break it how do we break
free how do we solve that problem well
that's that's the billion dollar
question and that's what I wake up
every day trying to fix and I can give
you a couple things that I've worked on
that I found helpful and hopefully helps
move the needle they don't have all the
answers but but some of these might help
the first one is to change your
environment the environment makes such a
huge difference for who you are and your
daily habits and what you believe about
yourself and the environment is not just
the people who are around you although
that definitely helps you know if you've
got negative friends or family around
you you want to eliminate them
completely or spend a lot less time with
them because it's really really really
hard to have a beautiful plant grow when
it's just you know toxic waste being
poured on top of them doable but really
really difficult and so changing that
can really help and
one of the best ways I found to do it is
content
it's content it's why I make so much
content for these channels that
hopefully
you wake up today and there's a piece of
content there waiting for you whether
it's me or showcasing somebody else
across all my channels we're making
multiple pieces of content every single
day to try to hit it in the right way
maybe today's message with the right
voice is the one that makes a difference
for you and if you can shift
the amount of entertainment you're doing
or just shutting off the world some of
the content that you consume just helps
you shut off the world and Escape versus
educational content that helps you learn
improve get better and solve the problem
right entertainment is let's forget
about the problem just laugh at
something else
education is let's learn to actually fix
the problem that is happening in our
life right I want to lean in on that a
lot more it doesn't mean that
entertainment doesn't exist in your life
it's not only education but if you can
shift the needle towards education to be
around the people who inspire you even
if you've never met them
it can really move the needle for your
your inner dialogue and your
self-confidence so the thing that saved
me in my first business in doing this
was modeling Bill Gates or Microsoft
when I I quit on my business partner I
struggled I didn't know you know I felt
worthless nothing was working I was
working every day and just no results in
in looking at Bill Gates's story that
that changed my life it saved my
business it allowed me to keep going
because now I had a little bit of hope
that Bill Gates could do it maybe I
could too and the more you surround
yourself with those people
the more you'll feel like you can do it
too so do an audit how many people in
your life the the actual humans that you
know and also just the people that you
subscribe to that you follow how many of
them make you feel better about yourself
and for too many people it's it's not
enough you know it's it's look at who
you follow on YouTube look at who
subscribed to
um look at who you're connecting with on
Instagram you know if you're loading
your phone you're going through
Instagram or you're watching YouTube
videos how many times have you gone
through it and all of a sudden an hour
has gone by and you were mindlessly
watching videos or even worse make you
feel worse about yourself you ever felt
that you watch a video and then you feel
worse about yourself afterwards or
you're following somebody and it makes
you feel worse about yourself you have a
choice to unfollow those people this is
not Instagram's fault or YouTube's fault
you can take accountability here you
have a choice to unfollow those people
and then a choice to follow the people
who make you feel better about yourself
that's my aim with all these videos I
want to leave you with strategies but
also more belief in yourself at the end
of every video and if I do that I
awesome you want more belief in your
life come back you know another shot of
espresso tomorrow morning we're here and
if I don't do that cool thank you for
giving it a shot and and don't quit on
that go find somebody else who gives you
the motivation inspiration that you need
and so you can make a conscious choice
because it's so easy to stay stuck it's
so easy to stay small it's so easy to to
be the one that pours in other people
and not have anybody pour into us and
you need to make a conscious choice to
to raise your environment to change your
environment and it doesn't mean you have
to go move to a different country or
move to a fancier house or anything else
you start by just changing who you
associate with even at a mass scale
right
I've learned a lot from Steve Jobs I've
been inspired by Oprah Winfrey my
favorite entrepreneur of all time is AP
giannini who started Bank of America
these are people who I've never met
you know and and in the case of jobs in
Janine I never you know will meet
because they've passed
but I've been inspired by them and
they've made me better and they've
taught me and I've learned from them and
they've inspired me and I get courage
from them
because I've consumed their content
and you can do that too
it's just being intentional about it so
that when you raise your environment you
raise your life
the second thing is try not to do it
alone
it's really hard to go after
a goal to change your mindset to
accomplish big things when you're doing
it all by yourself you know
it this is why a lot of people quit
because you might have one one amazing
day or you watch The Right video you
have the right experience and it's like
that I want this is this is the life I
want you ever had that right like this
is the life that I want this is who I
want to be this is this is where I could
go you have a glimpse of a potential
future that you could be it's like I
want that and you actually feel in your
heart that you can be that you can
accomplish that right does that happen
to you and then what happens the next
day you wake up and it's kind of gone
and then the next day it's completely
gone and then you're back to your old
life and the limiting beliefs and the
habits and and you know you gain back
the 20 pounds and like how did I end up
back here I thought I fixed this right
does that ever happen to you
a lot of it is because you're doing it
alone
and this took me a long time to figure
out
as an introverted person as a shy person
as somebody who doesn't like asking for
help
um
as someone who's afraid of disappointing
people
being a part of a community is not
it just sounds super scary to me
we just did our seven day challenge for
built to serve and a bunch of people
join movement makers uh we had almost
100 people joined movement makers at the
end of it and it's people who want to be
thought leaders and want to be speakers
and authors and coaches and course
creators and membership creators and all
of the stuff there's a big impact that
spread your message and I was giving
people
a lot of uh
not just encouragement but respect like
the people who ended up joining
I just had incredible respect for
because I wouldn't have done it if I go
back to 19 year old Evan when I started
my first business I wouldn't have done
it I wouldn't have had the courage to do
it I wouldn't have joined the group we
had people sharing their videos like
tell us about your your who your why
your how is your this methodology from
the book but make a video you know
sharing your purpose and your biggest
pain of all time and some of these you
know kind of deep uh things that you
have to record and share and I mean it
was optional not everybody did it but in
doing that
for a lot of people it was their first
video that they've ever done
for a lot of people it's the first time
they've even shared their story to
anybody that they were sharing things in
the group that they hadn't told their
spouse
you know or their family or their best
friend and now they're making a video
in their car
ing their story
and you see them become liberated you
see them you see them start super scared
and Afraid and unsure and fixing their
hair and you know apologizing for the
lighting not being good and them being
in the car and not knowing what they're
doing to then just seeing the
transformation of somebody
going through the Cocoon you know being
a caterpillar and turn into a butterfly
and sharing their story for the first
time and I was in awe because I I
couldn't imagine me doing that at 19
when I started my first business
I was too afraid to join a community I
was too afraid of being judged
I was too afraid of being not good
enough
and that kept me small
I kept my growth really slow
um
fortunately I kept going you know if
you've seen my my
chart on my website where I show how
much I've grown every year over year
over year over year where I've been took
five years to get the 7 000 subscribers
or something like that
and I just kept going and the one thing
that I've got was just tenacity and
drive and I will just keep going in the
face of adversity but I made it just
incredibly hard on myself being alone
not being open to sharing with my
friends what I was struggling with and
never joining the community
so I think that can really help you you
know I think I think trying to go and
change your mindset and accomplish big
things that nobody around you has done
yet and there are some days that you
feel incredibly inspired and motivated
and Powerful like yeah I can do this but
you're probably not living there most of
the time
what if you did or what if you lived
kind of close to that most of the time
and point number one of raising your
environment can definitely help
but Point number two is just don't try
to do it alone
even if it's one person you don't have
to join Movie Makers you don't have to
join a group
but even just one person
one person who you can talk to you can
connect with
who you can you know share your stories
with not just complain to not not talk
about how hard everything is and just
have somebody to vent to but somebody
who supports you
if you had a group of people who
supported you
where you felt welcome we felt like you
weren't alone in this journey we felt
like people understood you
and we're actually genuinely cheering
you on to go you know become the person
that you want to be
Everything Changes
so raise your environment
get a community and watch your impact
happen rule number four break the
negative patterns you can change the
negative patterns that I run in your
life
the patterns that you think are
impossible to break that have been with
you for life that will be with you for
the rest of your life you can break them
it starts with a decision and if you
don't want to still be in 20 years
living by that same negative pattern
that is holding you back
I think this video will help most of
what we do is subconscious most of what
we do is beneath the surface most of
what we do is
what we've been conditioned to do and
the patterns that we've seen and you
know if you're watching this you're
likely an adult and we've been running
the same pattern programming for a
number of years if not decades and
it can be really difficult to be able to
switch that pattern but I'm going to
give you a formula today that I think
will really help and one that I'm
applying myself as well in my life so
step one
is even just acknowledging that the
pattern exists and that you want to make
a change
what is the habit what is the negative
Loop that's in your mind what is the
thing that you don't want to still be
thinking in the next year two years five
years ten years what is that thing one
of the things that I'm working on is
moving to a space of great things happen
to me I had a great video coaching
session with Beth hendel and my big aha
moment that came from there was
I believe in the plan
so whenever I am thinking of something I
make a plan and then I execute the plan
and I do the plan and I follow the plan
and when I don't believe in the plan
then I create a new plan then I believe
in that plan and that's the thing that
gets me going so I'm very plain
scheduled calendar oriented that gives
me my security that gives me my identity
and so as long as I have a plan easy
peasy let's go waking up we're making
videos because it's in the plant
but then what happens on the rare days
you know maybe once a month where
I don't believe in the plan anymore I
don't think the plan is good enough to
get to where I want to go
and I can't make a new plan I don't know
what the next plan should be what I have
done so that I don't get lost and
spiraled down into negative thinking
into uh maybe not depression but
um anxiety and stress and overwhelm that
I don't know what to do next you ever
been faced with that like I don't know
what to do next
my plan has been my plan see I'm using
the words
just to tell myself
great things happen to me this is what
I've done it's been my coping mechanism
the the way out of the stress and the
anxiety and not knowing what to do next
is me telling myself great things happen
to me
and what Beth challenged me to do
and the big Insight that came from it
was living not in the identity of the
plan but living in the great things
happen to me so now I'm trying to shift
my identity from being the guy who
believes in the plan to being the guy
who believes that great things happen to
me that instead of using great things
happen to me just as a coping mechanism
on my worst days the once a month days
when I really don't believe that I'm I'm
getting closer to my goals or I'm never
going to hit them
and flipping that to being the default
mode that's that's really hard I've I've
was not born the plan guy it took me
decades I'm 42 coming up in May I'm 42
and it took me decades to become the
plan guy you know two decades to become
the planned guy
and now I'm I'm not
getting rid of the planned guy thank you
plan guy you got me here I appreciate
you you know Pat in the back I still
need you please stay with me on this
journey but I want to be the guy who
believes the great things are coming
because at the end of the day all your
great things all your great ideas all
your great breakthroughs usually don't
come as a result of the plan
it's maybe a byproduct of the plan but
not a direct result of the plan because
the plan only is something that you know
exists right now it's it's what I've
talked about making decisions with your
head versus your heart big decision with
your heart and song with the head the
head only understands the world that
currently exists where your heart can
create something brand new and so I want
to be I want to be in the brand new I
want to create something that hasn't
been done before and so the you can't
plan for something that hasn't been done
before and you need to have some faith
that great things will happen and so
that's a long way of me saying that I am
trying to become
the guy who believes that great things
happen to me as a default state
I believe that when I say that when I
create video and I say that on camera or
when I'm talking I believe that I
believe the great things come to me if I
keep going if I keep making if I keep
sharing if I leave with my heart if I
tap into what I feel is the right thing
to do even if it doesn't make sense I
believe that great things will happen
and I've seen enough of that happen over
my life and career that I believe it and
if you're not quite there yet
just look for some small wins that when
you have help when you have shared when
you have created from the heart you've
gotten some small wins and if you keep
going you can have
slightly bigger ones and medium-sized
wins and then large ones and then
gigantic wins if you just keep going so
how do I shift and we're working through
this in real time I'm not sharing a
story that is you know
it's 20 years old like I sometimes might
do the foundation story so how do I
shift how do I shift from being
the plan guy to the great things will
happen to mikai I think it could be
useful
Mini case study for you if there's
something that you want to work on
that you want to improve at you're tired
of telling yourself a different story
and you want to shift it so here's what
I'm doing first off is trigger words
right so if I say plan that's a trigger
word plan ooh plan here's my plan like
oof plan I said it again not that it's
bad right for years it might be bad it
might be it might be a critical you
telling yourself that you're stupid or
that you can't or it can't it could be
another a trigger word or hard it's
another trigger word the fact that
you're not going to do something because
it's hard that's a trigger word right so
what are the trigger words that you tell
yourself as to why you can't do
something or that keep you locked in
your negative patterns what are those
trigger words that anytime you catch it
you say it you feel it you tell somebody
else it that like oh there it is again
I'm noticing it and you can tell the
people in your life your your family
your friends your spouse people on your
team you can tell them hey if I ever say
this word I want you to I want you to
call me out of it so you can have people
kind of support you through this journey
as well number two is you try to design
in a conscious way
applying it in your life consistently so
the next thing I did as soon as I got
off that coaching call with Beth was I
told Nina I told my wife and I said hey
great things happen to us I told her
what happened and great things happened
to us great things happened to us great
things happen to us and I honestly I
must say that at least 40 times a day
great things happen to me don't talk to
myself or great things happen to us
if you want you can set it as a alarm in
your phone you could put it as a
background on your on your computer
screen you can put it as a sticky note
on the bathroom mirror or the door I
have a email that I sent myself that I
didn't delete out of my inbox so so I
always see it in my inbox every day when
I'm checking my email I check my email
once a day and it's always the last
email that I that I checked because I
never removed from my inbox and it says
this is your great things happen to
reminder
yeah
this is your great things happen you
reminder every time oh that's right
great things happen to me because that's
still not it's nowhere close to being my
default
but I'm working towards becoming that
person
so it's the decision to do it and then
with intention putting things into your
calendar so that it happens so again
maybe you're setting an alarm on your
phone maybe you're putting the picture
up on your wall you're telling your
friends and the people around you and
you're finding a way to repeat it to
repeat it to repeat it to repeat it and
I'm not judging myself as to I need to
get this done next week
I just want to make a little bit of
progress every day Beth's team reached
out and wanted to do a round two of
coaching and I said I'm still I mean
thank you it's amazing I'm still working
on the last thing you know the great
things happen to me
shift in mindset is something that I'm
working through and
it's incredibly powerful and I don't
think I need any help for anything else
yet I'm still working through this thing
this week has been a really challenging
week for anina and myself as well we are
we ran our build to serve challenge
which which was crazy
um when we first did it the the idea
that was pitched to me was seven days 45
minutes to an hour each day and we ended
up going the seven days and you know
three to four hours each day which I
didn't budget for but it was amazing
helping thought leaders and speakers and
coaches and entrepreneurs authors
just the energy and the vibe and the
love was so amazing that it took up an
incredible amount of time at the same
time we just bought a a brand new house
which is super exciting and so selling
this place and so I had to move my up
you might notice it's a different
background than usual I'm not I guess I
could have done it in my car
um but I'm not in my usual Studio my
office because we have a makeshift
office while we get our place ready to
list today
so we're packing and moving and
switching all the artwork and all of
that stuff while running a challenge uh
yesterday I hit the side of a a curb
that had a rock
not a rock like a boulder and it
punctured my tire and not just like
giant hole in my tire uh so okay we have
to go and get the car fixed on top of
everything else which is why I can't
film in the in the car like I normally
do because I don't have a car right now
because it's being fixed because we I
blew out the tire and just issue over
issue over issue and
my niece was with us yesterday
and she made a comment to my wife Nina
about how calm we were through
everything like okay well the car tire
got blown out uh that's that completely
changes how we spend the rest of today
now instead of doing these errands and
taking people here and all of this stuff
uh on Nina's birthday by the way
it's like okay well here's what we need
to do now you know okay we gotta get
fixed we gotta figure out how to solve
these other problems and let's go and
she was my niece was blown away but how
we weren't arguing or fighting or
yelling or
uh super stressed just okay let's solve
the problem and keep moving on with our
day why because great things happen to
us
great things happen to us and that's you
know when something negative going on
even if it doesn't feel real
it'll be something that Nina and I will
laugh over great things happen to us oh
that happened okay great great thing you
know what great things happen to us
figure out a way through this great
things happen to us and in that ongoing
conditioning
the more that it's around us the more
that I say it I believe it a little bit
more and a little bit more and a little
bit more and a little bit more and I
guess you could call it affirmations I I
never really
connected to affirmations that much
because it felt
if I was saying something that I didn't
believe in that
that it wouldn't it wouldn't work for me
and because I already believed that it
wouldn't work for me then I've already
set myself up for feeling from the
beginning I think the key thing is if
you want to be able to change that
mindset you want to change the Habit
Loop you have to find something that you
actually on your best days believe
there's a kernel of Truth in there right
if you're 400 pounds and you say I'm
skinny I'm skinny I'm skinny I think I
think a lot of
in your head you say well that's BS I'm
not skinny and and then you don't
there's no even kernel of truth to it so
then you never do the actions to help
you get there where on your best days
what do you believe about yourself on
your best days how do you handle
problems
so when I say great things happen to me
I believe it
I actually believe that that wasn't
something that was given to me that
wasn't something that somebody once told
me that wasn't somebody that a coach
told me that okay you have to use this
now as your Mantra I believe it on my
best days I believe it I believe it I
can I can tap into that and I believe it
there's a kernel of truth to it and I
want to make that kernel you know grow
into something much much much much
bigger so homework would be to think
about
on your best days what do you believe
about yourself what what's the specific
language the specific words that you
would say to yourself to encourage
yourself or you're looking back and
you're proud of yourself on your best
days what do you believe about yourself
and then finding a way to make that a
daily part of your life
so that when the negative things come
you can tell yourself this as a reminder
and starts to shift everything for you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five believe in the
power of meditation so I have a slightly
different take on meditation and if
you've been struggling with meditation
in your life this might help I first off
believe in the power of meditation I
believe the science I believe all the
studies and and I used to judge myself
and feel really bad about it because I I
felt like I couldn't meditate I would
sit there on the couch or on the pillow
or on the bed or lie down and I never
felt anything when I was meditated I
could sit and I could be present and I
could I could I could do it and then and
I could sit there for 20 minutes and it
felt like 20 minutes
but I never felt any different I think
that was where it started to shift for
me is not that I didn't feel anything in
the moment but never felt any different
coming out and I've meditated with some
of the
the the best meditation teachers
um on the planet and it's never really
led to an impact for me uh in the moment
or afterwards or sustained and I again
would judge myself really harshly like
hey I mean how I want to make this work
how do I make this work I Believe In The
Sciences go and make it work
what I've distilled it down to is into
two parts one is a lot of meditation a
lot of benefits I believe from
meditation are really just about being
present and being Mindful and that is
something that I can do a lot more
naturally than maybe most people and I
don't find a lot of benefit in it
because I'm more there than not so I I'm
85 present 15 future focused and zero
percent pass focus when you are thinking
about the past it's usually really
negative way sometimes we like pass Look
Backwards into the past and it's
gratitude and and remembering great
memories and
um you know looking all the great things
we've done but for the most part when
you look backwards it's negative it's
regrets it's I wish I did this or why
did that person do that to me or I wish
I had said something different we're
we're looking negatively on our past
mostly through the lens of regret and
what you did or what other people did
and when you're looking forward
entrepreneurs love looking forward and
the vision and the building what you can
create and all the amazing things but a
lot of looking forward is also
uncertainty in Stress and Anxiety in
what may happen and what could happen
and what might happen if x happens and
just we're stuck in these negative Loops
a lot of the backwards thinking is
negative through the lens of regret and
a lot of the Forward Thinking is
negative through the lens of anxiety
stress and worry and so that's where hey
if you're present-minded you're going to
be a lot happier you're going to be a
lot more focused right if you're just
thinking about what you should have done
or what might happen to you you're not
actually able to be productive and get
stuff out right now in the present and
so the the job becomes how do I stay
present and I think a lot of that is
accomplished through meditation for most
people if you're if you're in a state of
stress thinking about the regret of the
past or anxiety about the future I think
meditation can be incredibly helpful to
help you get back to present even just
focus in on your breath breathe in
breathe out even something as simple as
that can help calm you down and get you
back to the present moment which then
allows you to
be able to be productive uh solve the
problem be happy because you're being
more present so for me that's actually
quite easy I'm in the present uh a lot
more than anywhere else and I used to
think it as a negative a friend of mine
used to make fun of me for having a bad
memory he's like you're such a bad
memory it's like and I later realized I
I don't have a bad memory I I want to
remember what's important to me but two
I'm not living in the past like I don't
care about what happened I'm looking at
right now today I don't know what day it
is I don't know what day it is I don't
know I I know it's 2022 when recording
this I'd have to think about what month
it is
I don't know what I'm doing after
recording this video I don't know what I
did yesterday I don't know what I'm
doing tomorrow let alone once I press
stop on this video I am here with you
this is this is my entire attention is
making this video right now that's it
this is this is the present moment for
me and what I've discovered is
this is meditation
at least the the portion of it where
you're getting back to present moment if
that's one of the main benefits of
meditation then this is meditation for
me I'm only in the present moment right
now being here talking with you guys and
that's it
and I realized that most of my life is
lived like that yes I love planning for
where I'm gonna go but most of my time
isn't spent in planning it's in in
executing in doing and I have to look at
my calendar to see what I'm doing
tomorrow or what I'm doing when somebody
asks me on a Wednesday what's your
weekend gonna look like
weekend I don't even know what I'm doing
in the next hour let alone what I'm
doing this weekend and when people ask
me on a Monday how was your weekend like
I don't know
that was that was that was yesterday
that was two days ago I'm I got stuff to
do right now I'm working on my life
right now and and not just work even
just enjoying even just life even just
me spending time with with my wife or my
son or on a trip it's like let's enjoy
this moment where we're at right now and
so if that's you I would introduce the
idea of hey that's a different
perspective shift like maybe you are
meditating right now and you might be
over judging yourself because if you're
in the present that's one of the biggest
benefits one of my favorite things to do
every morning is I go on a belief walk
and I found when a lot of people would
say oh I get my best ideas when I'm
meditate it if I get creative
breakthroughs when I'm meditating part
of that that I believe is hey you've
unblocked yourself from the past and the
future the regrets of the past the
stress of the future to get back to
present which then calms you down to
then that should be more creative and
solve the problem I found I wasn't
getting I wasn't really getting answers
I wasn't getting Solutions I wasn't
being very creative of sitting down
lying down and having my body be still
where I get a lot more of my energy and
creativity and ideas when I'm moving so
I get a lot of ideas
when I'm walking so I do a believe walk
every morning which is 30 to 60 minutes
I'll take the dogs out and then I'll go
for a walk usually the Tim Hortons grab
myself a coffee Canadian coffee brain
here and
No Agenda just think about what what am
I doing today you know what what day is
it what I want to accomplish today uh
taking some fresh air get a fresh
perspective and the the act of moving I
find gets my creativity flowing a lot
more I get ideas in the shower you know
when I'm when I'm moving have you got
ideas in the shower I think that's
meditation maybe it's a different
version of it a different definition of
it but I think that's meditation where
you can calm down when you can focus on
present and you get some great ideas to
come I'm selling my place we just bought
a new house we're selling this place and
the studio looks a little different
normally I'm filming in my car because
we're running some errands or my regular
studio and to get this place ready to
sell you you know we wanted to have a a
place that everybody could connect to
and so what my agent did was make an
office in a different room and I'm
sitting down and I have not sat down for
two years I don't know my last time I
like sat down to actually work and and
you might even notice me like I'm
Shuffling around a little bit like I
like to move normally I'm on a
trampoline and I'm bouncing 20 to 40 000
times a day and I got that because I
would find that when I did phone calls I
would much rather stand up and walk
around the office than just sit down and
so I'm a lot more creative and have a
lot more energy when I'm moving and
maybe that movement in my energy creates
movement in you know brain energy and
capacity and thinking creativity as well
but all of that is my form of meditation
and so any time that I would challenge
you to at least consider the fact that
anytime that you're present
anytime that you are focused on
something that you can consider that
part of the benefits of meditation
the second part of meditation that I
haven't fully connected to yet and I
don't have a solution for yet is when
you access theta waves and that's
basically when you're bouncing between
conscious and subconscious and where you
feel like
time flies so for me when I sit down or
lie down doing a meditation
if it's 20 minutes it feels like 20
minutes and I don't think I'm hitting
any Theta levels
um I can sit there and be present and
focus on my breath or you know I've
chewed a cookie for half an hour or an
hour and never swallowed it you know
like the focus and the presence I can do
but it still feels like it's 20 minutes
or half an hour or an hour I've never
had a I sat down for an hour and I felt
like it was I was only on for five
minutes
I get that more through the work that
I'm doing I get that more
um I recently did a six hour uh q a with
Tom bilyu's impact community
on his Discord and
it was six hours I didn't go to the
bathroom uh I didn't take a break I was
I was reading the questions and
answering the questions my throat was
burning didn't even notice it till the
end and had that six hours flew where
that felt if you asked me how long was
it I would have said I don't know I was
like 20 minutes half an hour like six
hours six hours later still going and
then we eventually wrapped it up because
I needed to go to dinner
my wife where I said yeah I'm gonna do
this short little q a and turned out to
be six hours
so maybe that's even a better form of
meditation maybe maybe when you're in
your purpose and doing great work and
time flies because you're having fun
maybe that is a better form of
meditation for you if you struggle with
just sitting down and meditating maybe
doing that work is healing you know I
think a lot of people meditate to heal
and I think of a part of why that could
work is because you're again removing
the stress of the past of the regret of
the past and removing the anxiety and
stress of the future and when your
body's all stressed out it's not going
to heal right but when you get back to
present and remove the stress you create
the conditions for healing in your body
well I remember when I broke my neck in
2019 and I kept doing my tour I kept
staying on it because I wanted to be
around entrepreneurs I wanted to keep
doing the I could have canceled the tour
wouldn't have been a big deal but that
became healing for me in feeling like I
was serving that I was helping sitting
at the front of a room for four hours
with
immobilized neck brace on ice packs you
know on my neck two or three pillows
behind me and I couldn't move for four
hours but just talk
that became healing for me
and so
at least what's helped me for where I'm
at right now I'm totally open to to new
experiences and being changed and you
know swaying my opinion before I'm at
right now
staying present
and doing
not just the work but doing activities
that you enjoy that you feel are in
service to others that you feel like
you're living your purpose that you feel
like you're having an impact think about
the things that you love doing where
where hours get lost I'm not talking
about like opening your phone and
scrolling through Instagram when you
realize that two hours have passed and
like how did I just waste all this time
not that but
in service of others and helping to see
I'm moving around right now I gotta move
I can't sit still
I don't like it when I get in creative
ideas I gotta move I play with my ring
you know they got the ring is all over
the place it's not just on my finger
this this gives me more creativity like
the motion creates more creativity for
me
and so if you find those things where
you love doing it's in service to others
is helping people time gets lost and you
feel it in your heart and your soul that
this is the right thing for you to be
doing for where you're at right now
that maybe that's you know maybe just
maybe that's the form of meditation that
you need the most
that
by staying present and helping others
and being in service maybe that's all
the healing that you need
maybe that is the present mind that you
need maybe that is the focus that you
need maybe that is the meditation that
you're already doing
and if that gives you some extra
perspective or a different view on
meditation than what you might hear
other places I hope that helps maybe
judge yourself a little bit less or
maybe lean into something that you
thought didn't exist because this
certainly played a huge impact on my
life and thank you for allowing me to
share the story with you rule number six
focus on one thing focus on one idea and
make it work focus on one business model
focus on one Revenue stream focus on one
social media Network and make it work so
many times we're focused on too many
things we're distracted and our
entrepreneur ADHD kicks in and as a
result nothing happens for all the
people who are telling you to have 13
different passive income streams because
if one goes away you still have all
these other 12. most people who start
off doing that make zero money from all
of the passive income streams you're
making ten dollars a month four dollars
a month seven dollars a month where
instead if you could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
built to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people got a big
message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the answer
is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much much better it doesn't
mean that you can't be there you know it
doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
we have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether to social media success
whatever it is what you have to figure
out is how do I start to as soon as
possible get a sustainable business for
myself so that I can quit my job if you
have one so that I can bring income in
for myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster and
so if you want to go and accomplish your
big goal your big dream your big mission
then it's important to think about the
sequence of things that instead of doing
everything all at once and as a result
all of the results being mediocre focus
on the one thing that if you push that
lever you really maximize that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
and I can do so much more you know
because we got team then if it was just
me by myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford to
hire team that helps me accomplish a lot
more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I can pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money but then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start like look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big goal and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I look at a lot of thought leaders a lot
of people have a message a lot of people
want to be speakers and authors and
coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching
if we had those are four opportunities
in front of you right let's say so what
did I say being a speaker getting paid
to speak getting paid to do brand deals
getting paid to be an author and selling
books even selling courses your own
materials and training and Etc and
coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
be coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you could do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
get paid immediately while we work on
the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet you don't have a brand yet so could
it work absolutely will it pay you more
than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than
coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
I'm much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service and a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem
and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
like when is it going to come out what
year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
right how much time has gone into your
course it's like we start and stop and
start and stop because we're tackling so
many different things because you want
to do it all and you want to have income
streams coming in like crazy and there's
nothing wrong with that it's amazing but
there's a sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
we just need to focus it's all possible
your big dreams are possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus rule number seven work harder
people aren't afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street corner you'll
record a video but you'll never release
it you'll be your own biggest critic but
you won't at the same time also be your
own biggest fan that needs to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
it's led to some positive things and
that I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm giving you still more than
made the money that you invested into
any of the stuff that I'm doing but at
the same time it's still this fear and
so I want to attack the fear I teach
myself to attack the fear and I think
you should too an example was when I did
my tour
90 days 23 cities and I I did a paid
tour because I was afraid to do it and
this is supposed to be a free tourist it
was supposed to be coffee shop meetups
across the U.S low res super easy if one
person shows up great if nobody shows up
awesome if 100 people show up great
there's no risk right it's free you come
don't come whatever and my agent said
that's that's plain and small you got to
charge for the event and my first
reaction was oh my God I can't charge
for this event right like
choking up because I'm afraid because
I'm afraid that that if I start charging
for it then I need to I need to bring so
much more value
and because that was the reason that I
had to go off and do it if there was a
strategic reason why I should do a free
event then that that's fine my next tour
I'm looking at for 2020 is going to be
free is going to be ideally fingers
crossed I get my book deal it's going to
be at bookstores with my new book launch
so I want to do 20 something cities east
coast uh Texas Mexico with my book
launch and it's it's free to come
hopefully you buy a book but it's you
know not required but it's free to come
out because it's going to be supporting
the book launch that's a strategic
reason why I should be free I didn't
have a good reason why the first one
shouldn't be free while the tour this
year shouldn't be free and so I had to
do it I had to step into the fear you
have to step into the fear and do it
because you need to attack the thing
that you're afraid of especially when
it's related to other people right I'm
not afraid of failing I'm afraid of
failing in front of other people I right
I can suck all day here in the office
but I don't want to suck in front of
somebody else I don't want to make
people feel like whether they're
spending 50 bucks to come and see me
that was on tour or 2 000 bucks to come
see me at my thought Leadership Academy
here I don't want people to feel
disappointed and because I feel that way
I need to step into it and I try to
teach myself attack it attack it attack
it if there's no Goods to teach a reason
why then I have to do it because
otherwise I'm playing small and even
just attacking it for the sake of
attacking it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business it's good
because you're building strength because
you're pushing your comfort zone because
you're getting better because you're
growing that's worth something that's a
ton of value because if you can conquer
your fear of doing this one thing that
translates to every of your life if you
teach yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere
so maybe you're afraid of if you're on a
cruise ship and they they bring up
couples and they do a game show you're
afraid of what might happen on that game
do it
how does that make you a better
entrepreneur makes you a thousand times
better as an entrepreneur because that's
the same fear that you face in your
business that fear of going on that game
show on the cruise ship that fear of
taking your phone and recording a video
in public on the street these fears that
seem like nothing they show up
everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes
starts building the muscle who cares if
you fail on the street corner making a
video great go do it if that if that is
scaring you right now do it teach
yourself you do it you have courage you
do scary things
to come on the other side you'll come up
with more strength and then you'll start
seeing things happen in your business
you'll have more courage you'll have
more boldness you'll be more willing to
do things and then your business starts
taking off
you have to lose the fear of failing in
front of other people I'm going to give
you three ways on how to do it step
number one is embrace your bold ideas
I'm a big believer that when you have
these moments of boldness maybe it's
happening right now maybe you're feeling
bold right now watching the video
amazing you have these moments of
boldness we have moments of boldness I
don't think people are bold all day long
right and if you are then you have
moments of even greater boldness hear
these moments these spikes these hits
right you go to an event I look at
people come to my thought Leadership
Academy they have these huge moments of
boldness right and then you fall back
down
and that's normal you're watching a
movie you get inspired you fall back
down you have a conversation you get
inspired you fall back down the
decisions that you make in the moments
of boldness I believe are the right ones
for you
those are the decisions you have to
follow through on an Embrace and then
your head talks you down from them the
head brings you back down the plane
small
and so when you're feeling bold what
have you come up with I want to go do X
you have to do what do it you have to
start building momentum you have to
start committing to some other people
embrace the Bold ideas recognize that
those aren't the crazy ideas those crazy
ideas that come up with the affiliate
world are not crazy those are actually
the best ones for you you're just buried
under pile of garbage of limited beliefs
on top of you those are the things you
have to go chase down and when it gets
hard when it gets difficult when you
want to quit remind yourself this idea
can be when I was feeling bold I have to
do it because I do bold things you teach
yourself step number two is expect to
suck this is where it gets super
liberating expect to suck the first time
you do anything expect to suck why do
you expect to be great the first time
out what do you expect your first video
that you make to be great it's not
it'll suck that's the best it should
suck right if you are if you are amazing
and making your first video then you
should have started making videos four
years ago I believe that you waited too
long you're first at anything should be
terrible doesn't mean that you suck I
think you're amazing you're a genius
you're Michael Jordan you're the best of
all time at something
but Michael Jordan didn't didn't dunk
his first ball right he didn't he didn't
shoot and it went in right away right
you suck at the beginning that's normal
learning any
Skillet looks good if you want to be a
basketball player you know what a good
basketball player looks like if you want
to be a YouTuber you know what a good
YouTube video looks like but then you
can't do it yet your first one sucks and
that's where most people quit because
they expect to be good they're worried
about looking bad in front of other
people they're not good the first time
out and so then they never go back to it
and this is what happens when when
people are are growing up you fail all
the time it's normal it's okay you fall
down awesome you get back up you keep
going and then we stop trying as adults
how often you try new things how often
are you willing to risk failure to risk
losing to risk looking like a fool
you don't want them so you're not trying
as much anymore and you never find the
thing you could be Michael Jordan at you
never find it and you get stuck in some
life and some job that you hate forever
that's most people I don't want that to
be you you need to try more you need to
explore more you need to expect to suck
the first 18 times of doing something
you may suck amazing keep going the most
important thing is are you liking it do
you like the process successful people
love the process I love making videos I
like this process this fires me up I'm
just sitting here by myself in my office
talking to a camera I love it this is
great I love it for other people they
may hate it amazing don't do that go do
something else go go build little Teemo
toys right awesome whoever made this who
made this
designing California oh they didn't even
they didn't give them credit all right
design in California
right go make toys go do something go to
the thing that you love
expect to suck but if you love the
process of it you will get better
think about when you whatever you
learned in school most of it you've
forgot
but this thing that you remember the
stuff that you connected with that you
like more so when you love something
you're going to just learn it a lot
faster
when you like something you're going to
get better a lot faster even if you suck
at the beginning you'll get better a lot
faster you have to find that thing and
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result what I want
you to do is go home and then sleep and
think am I proud of my effort am I proud
of what I did today am I proud of the
effort that I put in today I want to be
proud of my effort today in making
videos when I'm trying my best maybe
it's not good enough maybe today sucks
awesome but I'm trying I'm proud of my
effort I'm proud of the attempt most
people tie their software to winning to
the results to the money to the gold
medal to the to the whatever right to
the YouTube to the plaques back there
you can't do that because if you tie
yourself Worth to winning
you're only going to do things that you
know you're gonna win at
and therefore you play small for life
if you value winning above everything
else
you'll only do the things that you know
you're going to win at and so you play
small for life you stop trying new
things because you're gonna fail at the
beginning right expect to suck you don't
expect to suck you expect to be great
and then you're not and so you stop
doing that thing you'll only take on
small projects but you're capable of way
more you keep both doing something much
bigger
and so when you tie yourself forth to
the effort when you say I am proud of my
effort today
if you did that every day you're gonna
probably lose way more than most people
right you're going to be getting up and
losing almost every day and then you
have these big wins
but when you look back on this year of
losing you'll see holy cow how much have
I grown and you're actually winning way
more than most people way more than who
you used to be because you're proud of
your effort if you get up every day and
you're part of your effort
your life will change your business will
change like every day for the next year
do something that makes you proud of
your effort in your business in your
relationship proud of your effort you
tried your very best today
your life will be dramatically different
but it's because you're so focused on
winning you're so focused on the results
but then you you play small because you
don't want to risk losing you don't want
to risk failing your own risk looking
like an idiot
you have to if you want the life that
you're after
Michael Jordan missed more shots than
most people
you're going to fail at most things most
my videos suck and don't go anywhere
but get up try again be proud of your
effort every single day rule number
eight surround yourself with optimism
her environment is
Q Where You Are your environment has
been perfectly designed to keep you
exactly where you are right now the
people you listen to the media that you
consume the habits that you do daily all
of them all of them are designed to keep
you exactly where you are so if you want
to raise your game if you want to raise
your life you need to raise your
environment I've changed a lot over the
course of having this YouTube channel
the people who've known me the best and
the longest especially in the past two
to three years I've said Evan you've
changed a lot for the better you've
evolved you're more confident you have
more more Poise you're a better speaker
you you're pushing the boundaries more
you've changed what happened how do I
get that for myself right people wanted
it whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving other people they
want it they want a taste of it they
want to do it too because we are not
designed to just photocopy Our Lives
over and over and over again so how did
I get it I paid more attention to my
environment I paid more attention to my
daily routines I paid more attention to
the people that I hang around with it's
important so looking at my physical
environment right look at the look at
this office look at the people behind me
this all means something to me looking
at the new design that I've had here
below putting things like my neck braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me I walk into this
every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
the the people that I profile I'm
learning from I feel like I have garyvee
in my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my
ear I've got Elon Musk tell me what to
do pushing me to try to get better I
hear these people talking about you have
to be courageous you have to be bold you
have to believe in yourself more and
when I feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary and it should be
where am I going next I don't know I'm
still a work in progress but the more
that you are around people who push you
who make you better who make you want to
do more who pull you up to their level
guess what the more you're gonna get
there the alternative is you're stuck
where you are you stick with your
friends you stick with the media you
consume you stick with the habits that
you have and listen if you love your
life awesome if you're good then you're
good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment you need to change it
because everything you're doing right
now is keeping you on the path that
you're on maybe there's been some growth
if you look at who you were five years
ago compared to now you've grown if
you're watching this channel you've
grown right you've made some changes but
is it drastic enough like are you proud
of where you're at look at where you've
come from in the past year two years
five years are you proud of where you're
at and are you comfortable with that
same level of growth for the next five
years if not if you think I want more I
want to help faster I want to have a
bigger impact faster quicker
then the fastest way to do it is to
change your environment so if that's you
I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I think will help step
number one is cut out negativity just
cut out the people who don't serve you
sometimes those are friends that you've
had from kindergarten or high school or
university
you're in the Friendship out of
convenience now there's a lot of people
who you might need to let go of you
might need to just let them go They
don't serve you anymore you've you've
walked your parallel path together and
now they've gone out well they've
probably just stayed here while you've
gone out here
They don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake because they're
keeping you where you're at because
their negativity they're complaining
their unwillingness to change their
pessimism their laziness they're not
chasing down goals that that becomes
toxic even if you're trying to be a
beacon even if you're trying to be the
person who pulls everybody up
if all you're doing is trying to pull
other people up and there's nothing
pulling you up
you're going to be limited for life
when I went to the Tony Robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a fire walk
and the whole idea is to do something
scary well I went home to my Airbnb at
the time and and I did the scary thing I
didn't I skipped the fire walk at Tony's
event to go home and do the real fire
walk which was letting go of some people
that that I had been around for in some
cases a decade plus that this doesn't
serve me anymore I'm I'm doing this just
out of convenience instead of something
that's actually helping me grow and so I
need to shed the skin so that I can be
reborn like does this new skin none of
you that's trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that so you gotta let go
of the negativity sometimes that might
be family and with family maybe maybe
you should cut out some of your family
members from your life maybe maybe
that's that sounds drastic but maybe you
should a less drastic version of that is
just don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
see I don't I'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
at what point is this your life this is
your life your parents your the people
around you they love you they want you
to have success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit the conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted doesn't
really get the choice of where it gets
planted but you you get to choose you
get to change your environment so choose
powerfully and cut out the negativity
from your life step number two is then
seek out optimism seek out positivity
seek out things that make you grow that
make you want to learn that make you
want to push yourself right I have my
channel that's really helped me that
every day I wake up and I'm surrounded
by positivity and optimism and belief
and things that drive me forward that
even if I've I've had a rough sleep or a
bad day or or whatever it might be I see
Steve Jobs right next to me staring me
down I have my parents behind me looking
at me encouraging me putting belief back
in me I've got videos to go to that will
build me up I've got my believe playlist
of music that I listen to that will
change my state and bring me back to a
place of optimism positivity what is it
for you
is it people do you need to be around
people physically can you go to meetup
groups can you go to the library or
coffee shop can you go join some
entrepreneur circles can you become a
part of a co-working place can you be
around people
that that are positive that are
energizing for you or can it be your
physical environment right or can it be
your habits and your routines or can it
be the the media you consume what are
you consuming what are you watching on
TV
or on Netflix is it is it entertainment
are you just shutting off your life to
try to forget about your problems and
just be entertained or you're trying to
educate yourself to build a better life
this is this is one of the fundamental
problems in the world right now people
they have problems you have problems
most people choose entertainment as a
way to forget about their problems
instead of Education as a way to make
their problems better do you want to
shut off the world
and and laugh at somebody else's expense
and watch big brother and see man that
person's life sucks
or do you want to go build a better life
for yourself
most people don't want to do the work to
actually build a better life I hope that
you do because that's how you actually
end up being happy do you want to numb
it with drugs do you actually want to
build a better life for yourself and in
Step number three is scheduled for
success
schedule for Success so what are your
daily habits what's in your calendar
what is the thing that makes you feel
bold alive contagious you know optimism
what's the thing for me it's watching
videos for me it's going through my 5S
schedule so I start the day with singing
where I have videos that are on YouTube
that just their songs that make me want
to sing make me want to dance make me
want to move it's the fastest way to
change your state I wake up tired and
maybe low energy and then I put on music
and it and it changes my state and makes
me happy do that for yourself don't put
on music that matches your current mood
put on music that matches the mood that
you want to feel like and it's the
fastest way to just in a snap be able to
change yourself we all have music that
makes you bounce and come alive start
your day with that right that's part of
mine so singing then Sun I like getting
Sun uh going outside being in nature
just having sun on my face not just
being stuck inside all day especially in
the morning makes a big difference my
third s is sore so I want to do
something makes me feel bold and come
alive and for me where I love my phone
here but for me I share a message I want
to share a message you want to feel like
the work that I do has meaning and
importance so I think about somebody
that I helped yesterday and then I share
a message on Instagram and Snapchat and
put it up that helps me soar what do you
need for yourself then I sweat so I'll
do a quick workout and then I do
something to scare myself right now it's
doing
um cold showers so I sweat and then I
take a cold shower and it's like and I
do difficult things that's my morning
routine right I called the five five and
a half s rule because
some days I'll start with a snuggle with
my wife in bed so we're seeing if that's
going to become like a 6S protocol but
at least it's five and a half right now
that's what makes me come alive you
might need something totally different
I'm okay with that that's amazing maybe
you need to meditate maybe you need to
pray maybe you need to pet your cat what
is the thing that you need to do to make
you feel bold and alive and and then
schedule that in so that you're not
hoping one day that something happens
you're not hoping that you're gonna meet
the right person or hoping you're gonna
find the right video like demand
Excellence from yourself demand
positivity and optimism from yourself
every day because if you did if you were
bold coffin optimistic positive every
morning if you created that system for
yourself man what could you accomplish
in a year can you imagine
if you did something every morning that
made you feel bold and confident if you
felt bold and confident every morning
for the next year imagine the life and
business that you're gonna have it's
crazy it's wild right so you have to
create that you have to schedule for
success success will come from your
habits so look at your calendar what are
your habits and if you did these habits
would it lead to you becoming a success
rule number nine think cake think big
act small think big have a big goal Big
Dreams big desires big mission big big
Vision You're Gonna Change the World
think big let's go we love that as
entrepreneurs right let's think big and
change the world and act small
in that you got to do something
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum
where what most people do is if you're
just thinking big and feel like you have
to act big from the start
then nothing ever ends up happening and
that big goal dies within you
we are afraid of taking the first step
we are afraid of building momentum we
are afraid of people seeing us and
nobody's seen us I just finished this
seven day challenge uh and built to
serve helping people become thought
leaders and people are afraid of people
watching their content and what their
what those people are going to say and
they're equally afraid of nobody
watching their content so you're afraid
of somebody seeing what you're doing and
judging you and you're also afraid of
people not seeing what you're doing and
you're creating an obscurity so you're
afraid of being seen and not being seen
at the exact same time is it any wonder
why you're not creating is there any
wonder why you're not making is there
any wonder why you're stuck and just
planning and strategizing and making the
the perfect thing happen before
something ever happens is it ever any
wonder why if you want to start a
YouTube channel you're still stuck on
what the opening sentence is going to be
and what microphone you're going to use
and what camera and what lighting and
what the background and how your hair is
going to look and your wardrobe and is
there any wonder why you're still stuck
on that instead of just creating
because we're afraid we're afraid of
being seen and we're afraid of not being
seen at the same time and so we've
convinced ourselves why we can't do
something with with you know rational
logical reasons that we believe
are really you're just not making
content you're just not making progress
you're just not having the conversations
you need to have you're just not
building the business that you should be
building right whatever the thing is
it's just at the end of the day it's
just fear
and the thing that's missing is momentum
how I encourage people to get through it
is what I tell myself I expect to suck
at the beginning
whatever you do
when it's your first time expect to suck
right just expect to suck at the start
why do you think you're going to be
amazing the first time you go and create
something you're not it's gonna suck
it's it's not gonna be very good like
even objectively it's not going to be
very good probably
but that's okay it doesn't mean you suck
as a person
I think it's amazing I think the fact
that you're willing to try is an
inspiration and so whenever you're first
getting started off when you have
expectations and you don't meet those
expectations in this Gap this is the gap
that prevents you from taking further
action
how many times have you tried to do
something you got started you weren't
getting results like you thought you
would and you just quit right away how
many times have you
recorded a video watched it back we're
completely embarrassed by yourself and
then never posted it and never launch
your channel there's been people who
I've done interviews with as their first
guest on their podcast or YouTube show
or Instagram whatever and then they
never post it
they never posted because they are too
embarrassed to even launch the show and
it was it was even a decent interview
but the insecurities interference and
the doubts creep in and so they don't
they don't post it they don't do
anything about it where you just need to
expect the suck at the beginning
just expect the stock expected to be
terrible and that gives you the freedom
to go off and create because like
anything else whatever it is you want to
do you want to be a YouTube Creator you
want to be an entrepreneur you want to
be a coach an author a speaker whatever
it is that that your business is
it's all doable it's just a skill that
you need to learn there's there's a
bunch of skills that you need to pick up
and learn and like any other skill you
can learn it of course you can learn it
you can pick up any skill
but you don't have the skill right now
and so don't overly judge yourself for
not having the skill and not being good
enough as a human being just because you
don't have the skill set yet
right this isn't you're not good enough
as a human it's you're not good enough
at this specific skill set yet that when
you can figure that thing out and get
the training education experience then
you can go and accomplish the goal of
course
but we overly judge ourselves and then
we don't build momentum
one of my movie makers
uh his name is Michael he's he's an
amazing human he
wanted to start making content want to
start making videos wanted to start
doing interviews and he was he was
afraid of
asking people to be on the show and him
being the interview were he was fine
being an interviewee when people were
asking him questions but he didn't want
to be the interviewer and was afraid to
ask people questions and so we had a
discussion and we came up with a concept
where it was
his show called his show is called
empowering conversations with a disabled
man so he's disabled he wants to help
reduce the stigma around people with
disabilities he wants to have open
conversations he wants to help people
who are disabled find Hope and
inspiration and power and he also wants
to
educate able-bodied people to how to how
to help support cherish their disabled
friends or the community and so we came
up with a concept of empowering
conversations with a disabled man and he
launched his first live interview where
he was having the conversation he had a
guest come on and he was doing an
interview and it was the idea to action
that made all the difference because
he'd been thinking about doing a show
and thinking about making content and
you know being too afraid and being
stuck in his head like all of us do
myself included all of us do
and to his credit the thing that that
I did not do at his stage in this career
was he just went off and did it he just
okay you know what here's an idea I'm
gonna do something about it I'm gonna do
something about it I'm gonna get started
and he had his first one I asked him how
he did he said it was so much fun it was
so great it was so amazing and now he
scheduled the second one he's gonna keep
doing more it's a great win and that it
worked out now if he keeps going on this
show you know say he does 100 episodes
of the show he's gonna look back on his
first video and realize oh my gosh I was
so bad at the beginning right but look
at the journey look at the growth
same thing for you whatever you're
starting off doing and just expect to
suck at the beginning expect to suck
expect no results expect nobody to see
it expect it to be terrible and tomorrow
you're going to keep going you can make
it a little bit better and a little bit
better a little bit better and when you
look back on 10 days 20 days 50 days 100
days you'll come back and say holy cow
I'm really getting better why because
you developed a skill you were you were
still the same awesome human now you're
developing the skills to actually get
better at the thing that you want to do
makes all the difference the only thing
you're missing is momentum so just
repeat yourself repeat to yourself
the only thing I'm missing is momentum
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got the heart the care
the passion the desire to serve the
vision the just the soul to help you've
got all that you know you can help
oh you're missing is momentum
just not doing enough and that's not
that's not a beat down to say judge
yourself and you suck again as a person
and you should be doing more don't do
that
but take the time that you spend
criticizing yourself and judging
yourself for not being good enough and
use that energy to then just go make
something and expect to suck so a couple
things that help me that that that gives
me the permission to
to start so it's not a high bar it's a
it's there is no bar
there is the virus solo that there is no
bar and that gives you permission to
just start in the create momentum you're
looking for the other thing that I find
really helps me is
just trust that great ideas flow through
you
whether whether it's belief in self
whether it's belief in something higher
but just trust a good ideas flow through
you that if
an idea comes to you for something you
want to do trust it is a good idea trust
that that is the right idea for you that
you should do it that you should take
action on it and that it's going to
serve if you're in a positive mindset
right if you're if you're in a negative
mindset then then it's good to sleep on
your ideas right if you're in a jealous
mindset or hateful mindset or rageful
mindset then the ideas that come to you
are probably not the right ideas for you
but if you're in a powering empowering
inspiring positive optimistic mindset
then the ideas that come to you are the
right ones for you and just trust that
those are the right ideas and do
something on it and shortcut your brain
because as soon as your brain takes over
it's gonna be like oh okay but you don't
know how to do this and that and then
here's another problem and more
restrictions and you you know okay so
what happens default okay let's go
default to planning and researching and
we'll keep asking questions and we'll
keep him in high and then you know next
week I'll do something and then next
week comes and you haven't done it yet
right so when an idea comes to you
find the smallest possible way to get
started on it today
don't make it some big giant thing that
now you need a million dollars in
venture capital and a huge team to
accomplish
the only thing you're missing is
momentum right
so trust that great ideas flow through
you great ideas flow through you
you're here to do so much more
and take that kernel of an idea and do
something
whatever the smallest possible simplest
thing is to just build some kind of
momentum for it
to see how much did you love it how much
do you want to go back and do it
without having to pressure on it having
to be the perfect thing the next big
thing the only thing that matters
because that's what keeps you stuck
slow
knowing that you're capable of more but
too afraid to act
great ideas flow through you and the
only thing you're missing is momentum
let's go rule number 10
or a very special bonus clip be the last
line of defense happiness comes from
knowing who you are and then Having the
courage and confidence to step out onto
that ledge step out onto the ledge the
ledge
and go live it and go be you because
it's hard because it's tough because
you're going to get judged because we're
constantly comparing our version of
Happiness to somebody else I'm here in
Puerto Rico Brendan burchard invited me
down to speak to his Mastermind group
these people pay 30 to 50 000 a year to
be a part of it and I'm honored to be a
guest and
the thing that I see consistently from
all the people who are here right
imagine if you're dropping 30 to 50K to
be here how much are you making
so that you want to come down right
everybody's doing the thing that makes
them come alive and that's a secret of
Entrepreneurship at least the ones who
are successful
that your version of happiness is going
to look different than somebody else's
you're a weird duck that's awesome go
live it Brendan came on stage and
started talking about his daily routine
button doesn't do anything
work related typically until about one
o'clock he wakes up he walks the beach
he meanders he plays with his cat he
does all of these things that get him in
the right mental framework in his first
call is one o'clock
so he said that I want you guys to try
something
tomorrow go and walk the beach right
try that first thing in the morning he
moved the start time we're supposed to
start at nine start time to ten o'clock
because he wanted us to walk the beach
this doesn't experiment to see and I I
did it I went out and walked the beach
and it was good
but it's not the thing that brings me
happiness
right living in a
Tropical Paradise
it's not my thing
I like concrete
I like the concrete jungle I like being
steps away to everything I like insane
high-speed internet you know
the things that make me happy are going
to be different than Brendan Bouchard
would be different than you
I'm just about figuring out what the
heck is the thing that makes you happy
and then spending as much time as
possible doing that thing
a lot of it is still just a mind game so
how do you do it
start this process one think about
the people in your life that make you
happy
think about the people in your life that
when you spend time with them and then
you leave you feel more energetic than
before they gave you energy as opposed
to stealing it
then the funny calls it energy vampires
the people who suck your energy right
you lead them and you feel depleted most
people are going to be the energy of
Empires but you'll have some people who
are positive uplifting and when you
leave them you feel better about
yourself better about your life more
energetic ready to take on the week
ahead the day ahead the month ahead the
year ahead what have you who are those
people make a list of those people
I've been trying to spend more time with
them
try to find a project you can work on
together or if it's just meeting once a
month for coffee
try to spend more time with people who
lift you up and make you feel amazing
two
make a list of all the things that make
you feel happy in terms of activities
even League of Legends let me tell you
League of Legends if you don't know
League of Legends it's a video game I've
been playing for five years I'm not
particularly good at it I don't spend
enough time on it to get amazing but I
like it I love it it's fun in my in my
downtime I'm either salsa dancing or
playing League of Legends that's it
those are my hobbies I don't cook I
don't I don't want the beach
uh I don't Garden I don't I almost do
nothing it's entrepreneurship
League of Legends and salsa dancing
that's pretty much it I could come here
to Puerto Rico and never eat in any
restaurant
the first two days before Nina came here
the first two days I had cashews and a
hump Institute here
maybe not the healthiest like long-term
nutritional diet but no need to go out
and explore the different restaurants
it's entrepreneurship
League of Legends and salsa dancing
already in that there is a level of
happiness
because it's also saying no to the
things that I don't really particularly
enjoy doing I don't want to go to
karaoke I don't want to go out and try
this other place you know I don't want
to I'm good
I'm really I'm good this is what makes
me happy
talking about League of Legends was a
little bit
shameful I think at the beginning where
say that I was playing a video game
as opposed to doing something more
valuable or meaningful with my time
but now I talked about it
I like it it's fun and if you don't
think it's fine that's awesome and if
you want to judge me for what I find fun
go for it but you've got your own thing
everybody's got their own thing that
we're embarrassed to talk about that
we're ashamed to say out loud
and you can't be happy unless you do
you know garyvee's got his Jets he's got
the garage sailing
putting out garage saleing videos he got
judged a lot more
from his friends
you've got something like that too
I've got League of Legends
and so Having the courage to then say
this is me and to share it and to be
okay with it and to not be embarrassed
by it
Having the courage to go off and
actually start living that life to do it
to go and do it
what about yourself
that's where the happiness comes from
the third I would say make sure that
you're consuming content that makes you
feel happy
you know these videos I've gotten so
much from Gary I've gotten so much from
other people I've profiled it makes me
feel happier it makes me feel more alive
you know a lot I'm not hanging with Gary
every weekend you're not hanging with me
every weekend but you can get
videos
and you can remind yourself that this
world exists
and you want to play in it more often
as opposed to where you are because
where you are right now is where you
want to be and that's okay you don't
have to stay where you are forever
and so the things that will get you out
the things that will lead to the
ultimate happiness
is figuring out one what makes you happy
right I mean it's not the beach
isn't it I don't want to live here it's
great it's beautiful amazing but I don't
want to I don't wanna
I think those people hanging out on the
beach there with the umbrellas I think
they're nuts awesome go do you but it's
not for me understand what makes you
happy
hanging around with people who make you
do the activities that make you happy
consume the videos content resources
that make you happy
start now
because you deserve to be happy
you have allowed too many negative
voices into your head and they're
preventing you from achieving your
dreams maybe it's your friends your
parents your community the people around
you or worst of all maybe it's yourself
you cannot do great things with those
negative voices inside your head you
need to eject them immediately and this
video will show you how so I have a term
for those negative voices I call it the
little man the little man is the either
the voice inside your head or the people
around you telling you all the reasons
why you're not gonna win all the reasons
why this project this idea this dream of
yours is not gonna happen it's never
going to happen not a million years is
that gonna happen right we all have
people in our life who tell us that or
also us telling ourselves and the idea
for little man came from the very first
video that popped on my channel there
was a video called I believe that I
loved and it was when I just discovered
my who my one word which is believe I
just found out what it was and I wanted
to make kind of a tribute video to that
concept on my YouTube channel and I made
this video that was six and a half
minutes long or so and I showed it to
somebody who was in the entertainment
industry and I asked him to take a look
at it and he he just destroyed it he
said
this video is way too long six and a
half minutes uh nobody's gonna watch it
uh I didn't understand how the internet
worked all all sorts of comments about
how bad this video was and to be honest
a younger version of Evan might have
listened to him and tried to cut it down
and and make it fit within the box that
he wanted to be inside and
for whatever reason I just had a little
more strength and confidence and said
you know what maybe maybe he doesn't
like it but I'm just gonna I'm gonna do
it anyway I'm gonna post it anyway I
like it it inspired me and if it
inspired me maybe it was gonna Inspire
other people too so he posted it and at
the time my best video had a hundred
thousand views it took uh took a year to
get that video to 100 000 views this
video went live and in a month had a
hundred thousand views in the first
month at a hundred thousand views and
now sits around I think 2 million views
on the channel and so quickly became my
best video now it's not my best video
but at the time it was the first video
to you know pop after a month like this
is crazy it's taken up
and I thought man what if I listened to
the little man
what if I listen to him I came up with a
little man because it's something that
he uh often jokes about so he calls
other people the little man and said
like okay well he's the little man
what if I listen to him I would have
never done that video I would have never
never built the channel I would have
been in a totally different place a much
smaller place a much more negative place
a much more self-defeating place because
I was trying to you know fit into his
box and so you know I'm grateful that I
had the courage at the time at least to
trust my gut and go with it but it's
this constant battle that we face is the
voice inside our head telling us that
we're not good enough it's the people
around us telling us that we're never
gonna make it sometimes out of love and
sometimes out of insecurity and it's why
I think everybody has Michael Jordan
level Talent has helped them like you
could be the greatest it's why I believe
is the number one problem in the world
lack of belief is the number one problem
in the everything else is solvable
believing that you could be the Michael
Jordan of something that you you have
the ability to be the greatest in the
world at something that belief like
really feeling that you could be the
greatest in the world of something
how would your life change how would
your actions change how would it change
what you do today right you're watching
this espresso in the morning how does
your life today change if you actually
believe that you had Michael Jordan
level Talent at something
that's what I'm trying to do
and it starts with you kicking out the
negativity in your head we give up too
easily on our goals because we've proven
to ourselves that we can't follow
through on our goals every time you set
a goal and you don't follow through
you're creating the pattern in your head
the mindset the identity that I'm the
kind of person who doesn't follow
through
so what happens the next time you set a
goal well your brain will kick in to say
you're not going to do that how many
times have you set a goal for yourself
it might be some big giant goal right
like I'm gonna crush this year and I'm
gonna be here by the end of the year
awesome might be some big goal but
chances are even the little ones even
the little goals like I'm gonna work out
today or I'm gonna eat well today or I'm
gonna make that call today how many
times have you set even a little goal
for yourself and then not follow through
you didn't do it
you're not allowed to do that anymore
you have to be very intentional about
the goals you set for yourself and then
once you set them you have to follow
through because what's happening is you
don't believe you anymore
the next time you come up with another
goal you say I'm going to create this
thing I'm gonna get this thing done you
might believe it in the half second that
you decided you're gonna do it
I know what happens your brain's gonna
take over and say you're not gonna do
that thing are you crazy
what makes you think you're gonna do
that you didn't do these other 100
things you said you were gonna do either
your goals don't count until they're
hard
and it starts
with as soon as you set a goal you
follow through and expect it to be
difficult if it's easy it's a gift
expect it to be difficult and show
yourself that you do difficult things
self-love comes from doing difficult
things self-love self-confidence
self-respect all of it comes from doing
difficult things and praising yourself
for doing them I think it's one of the
most important things that people don't
do enough
but I think in order to actually make
the praise stick you have to prove to
yourself that you're worthy of it by
doing difficult things you can say I'm a
badass entrepreneur you can say I'm
amazed and I love myself but what your
brains ain't gonna say well no you don't
no you don't
show me what have you done you you're
waking up and then the same thing you
did yesterday at least this is the
conversation in my head so by doing
difficult things by doing the thing even
if you don't get the result
it doesn't matter about the result
you're tying your self-worth your
self-confidence to the effort to trying
the difficult thing the taking action on
a difficult thing that you were scared
to do if you woke up every day and did
something that made you scared that was
difficult that made your heart go boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom like that
you did that every day and then you
praised yourself afterwards for the
effort
I promise you you're gonna love yourself
I promise you're gonna go up and do
amazing things you're gonna take that
idea that you've got and go off and
actually execute it and actually
implement it one of the biggest reasons
why you're not is because you don't
believe in yourself that's why I think
lack of belief is the single biggest
problem in the world I'm trying to solve
the world's biggest problem people don't
believe in themselves enough the woman
who solves cancer is a manager at some
restaurant and she hates her life
because she never believed in herself
enough to actually go down the path that
you should have gone down because she
listened to her parents and friends and
family and decided to go do the safe
thing and she's got a safe boring life
she hates because she doesn't love
herself and she doesn't believe in
herself enough and so you have to do the
things that make you scared that are
difficult
that are difficult it's not about being
Fearless it's about feeling the fear and
still going off and doing it and then
saying I'm amazing because I try because
if you woke up every day and did
something where you felt amazing that
you tried
you're gonna actually go off and
accomplish amazing things and you're
going to feel amazing about yourself if
you want to stop living the life that
other people want for you you have to
understand your most important core
value I call it your who it's from my
book built to serve and when you figure
it out it gives you the freedom to start
living the life that you actually want
to live decisions become easier life
becomes easier and your confidence
starts to Skyrocket and I'm going to
tell you how to do it in this video so
my who is believe my one word is believe
it comes from my parents they're here on
my wall behind me I'm eight or nine
years old in this picture and my parents
are above me and they would always tell
me I'm Evan castrilly Carmichael that I
can do anything that I believe that I
can my favorite movie is Seabiscuit
which is about this horse that is too
small and a jacket that's too big and an
owner that has no money and somehow they
all come together in the middle of the
depression to to create this amazing
story I love cheering for the undertalk
I love the idea that if you just believe
in yourself more you're going to be able
to create amazing things and so believe
is my one word most important core value
it's my who so once you figure that out
it gives you Clarity over everything
else in in my life so look at the videos
that I make it's always positive all my
videos are always positive I always try
to inject believe into everything that I
do into this video right now right here
that you're watching hey what's up
YouTube welcome thank you for watching I
always try to make it about belief now I
may not achieve it I mean I've done a
good job you may not be feeling believe
after watching this but it's always my
intention going in it's why I don't have
negative videos if I did the top 10
stupidest things that Jordan Peterson
had said or the top 10 fights between
Kanye and whoever that would actually
blow up more that would that would blow
up more people would rather consume
negativity than positivity I just want
to make that video It Doesn't fill me up
it's not my purpose it's not why I'm
here creating the content that I'm
creating and so when you figure out what
your one word is when you figure out
what your who is your most important
core value it allows you to stay on the
path to create rate the life that you
want so if you come to me with an
opportunity that is not about believe
it's an easy no where otherwise it's hmm
should I do it I don't know the money
might be good but it feels a little
gross right it's an easier decision path
and if you're bringing people in to join
your team you now know what you're
looking for I need people who can yes
Video Edit hey Christina but I also need
people who believe and believe right who
want to help other people out so having
that Clarity gives you the rock to stand
on because you're going to be pulled in
a million different directions right
your parents want you to do something
your friends want you to do something
the news wants you to do something the
people around you are all telling you do
this and do this and do this and like
you don't know what to do and you see
somebody with confidence somebody who's
off chasing their dream and it's easier
just to say oh I'm gonna go and follow
that person where you could be an
amazing leader yourself the only thing
missing is you don't know what you stand
for when you figure out your who you've
got the rock to stand on when everybody
else is on quicksand and drowning you're
on your rock and you know what you need
to do the fastest way to accomplish
anything in life is to model success you
want business success you want
relationship success you want financial
success whatever it is you want to learn
somebody's done it and the fastest way
to learn is to go find somebody
understand what it took for them to
become a success and then apply it to
your business to your life to your
situation
the problem is we feel like we have to
do everything ourselves that you don't
know what to do so I'm going to figure
this out right I'm creative I'm a genius
I can I can figure it out and yes you
can but chances are it's going to take
you a lot longer
instead of trying to come up with
everything yourself it's better to build
upon what other people have already done
they could take you eighty percent of
the way it's not going to be a hundred
percent right if you're trying to get
big on YouTube great you can copy what
I'm doing but it's not going to take you
100 of the way it'll take you eighty
percent of the way because if all you do
is copy me you're going to be an Evan
Junior which will take you a good chunk
but at best you're going to be a junior
Evan you're never going to be what you
could be and so you need to take what
I'm doing learn from it but then tweak
that last 20 to make it your own how do
you take what other people have done and
then tweak that last 20 to make it your
own but modeling success takes you
eighty percent of the way
this is the biggest mistake I made when
I was starting up as an entrepreneur
right I told the story a bunch but I was
I was 19 I was struggling I was making
300 bucks a month I'm too embarrassed to
tell my friends that I'm struggling I'm
not having success I feel like a loser I
feel like I'm you know I'm not making
any money not just feel like it I wasn't
making any money and and I tried to
think my way out of everything I was
working my face off right like every
waking hour almost I was I was working
it wasn't for lack of effort I was just
doing the wrong thing so they didn't
know what to do because I was just
trying a whole bunch of stuff and then
that worst day of my life when I told my
partner that I quit
you know I just woke up the next day and
said I can't quit because I'm going to
regret this I know I'm going to regret
this advice if I stop now I'm going to
regret it I have to find a way to keep
going but the way that I've kept the way
that I keep going has to change because
what's going on now this this can't keep
going on if you're frustrated with the
lack of momentum towards accomplishing
your goals in life like if you're in the
same spot that you were a year ago or
relatively close the problem likely uh
could be lack of effort but is also
likely you're just doing the wrong
things you're just focus on the wrong
model and so go find somebody who's done
what you want to do for me I studied
Bill Gates I was out of
pure desperation I was not a genius when
I was 19 and trying to figure out my way
I was at Rock Bottom I just said
somebody has built a software company
before this can't be so hard right and I
looked at Bill Gates and how he started
right how did he start zero to one
that's what you need to study because if
you look at what people are doing now
one it
it's going to be hard to compare
yourself to if you compare yourself to
what I'm doing now I have 20 something
people on my team you can't like don't
expect yourself to keep up with what I'm
doing right now don't expect to keep up
with 11 years of experience right you're
not going to be as good when you first
get started that's okay but how did I
start how do they keep going whoever
you're looking at look at their
Foundation Story how they started and
chances are you already have more than
what they started with one of my
favorite quotes of all time is whether
you think you can or you think you can't
you're right it's usually attributed to
Henry Ford from all the videos that I've
made all of the successful people that I
profiled from industry Titans to monks
one of the things that they all have in
common is the ability to focus on the
things that they can do to improve their
situation there are a million reasons
why your idea will not work out and
eight while it will successful people
focus on the eight reasons why it will
succeed and unsuccessful people focus on
that million reasons why it won't so
it's time to decide which one are you
you need to make the big decisions in
life with your heart and the small ones
with the head big decisions with the
heart small ones with your head why
because your head only understands a
world that currently exists it's logical
it's practical it keeps you safe but
your heart can create something new that
hasn't existed before it's why the
number one rule for success is Follow
Your Passion all progress depends on
what your heart tells you to do and then
you use your head to figure out how to
execute it so I just got back from an
event that I was keynoting in Florida
and I was meeting these two
entrepreneurs and helping with their
YouTube channel and one of them is a
really logical head first guy and the
other one is a more heart-based
passionate guy and they were they're
asking me so that their Partners in the
same business and they're asking what's
more important logic or emotion logic or
emotion and there obviously the guy
who's logic base thinks logic is the
most important and the guy who's
emotion-based thinks emotion is most
important right you want to think that
what you're great at is the most
important thing and I told them it's
macro emotion micro logic macro emotion
micro logic you need to do both so as
I'm looking at their YouTube stats I'm
going deep into YouTube I'm telling them
all the data they need to know I'm
looking at the numbers and explaining
your audience retention sucks here we
need to fix it the percentage of
subscribers coming to your channel is
too low all of this stuff we're going
we're going deep into all their
analytics I can talk numbers for days I
love numbers I love making data driven
decisions but it's not the macro the
macro is the heart the macros why are
you on YouTube right why am I on YouTube
why am I making videos that's the macro
and then you use your head to figure out
the how the science of the thumbnails
and the audience retention and the
playlist and the titles and all of the
micro strategies that you can use on
YouTube to grow but it's macro motion
micro logic and so as I was explaining
it to him as I said it was listen it's
macro emotion he said but but I was
listening to you as you were explaining
things to me it was very logical
yes
the tactics were very logical but the
delivery so that you would understand it
and then go home and actually apply it
is emotion it's not logic it's emotion
because logic can be everywhere the
answers can be everywhere you know how
to lose weight you stop eating junk you
know how to get fit you'd start working
out you can find it but why are people
not doing it
because you haven't connected
emotionally the reason why you
understood what I was saying and you're
willing to take action is because of the
way that I delivered the information to
you because I had you control the mouse
and go through and do it yourself
because I was encouraging to you when
you needed it and I hit you in the face
when you needed it too not with my hand
with words
right it's macro emotion micro logic you
need both to win but just recognize the
situation you're getting into your big
decisions with the heart and then you
use your head to figure out how to do it
so it's common when you come with a new
idea for something you make a list of
pros and cons right and that's your
heart often talking against your head
where you have this giant list and you
say well these are all the reasons not
to do it but there's only one reason why
I want to do it and so if it's 10 con
and one pro what do you do if you just
look at numbers you go for the con but
maybe the one reason why is you just
love it
when you're heading your heart at
working together it's easy when you're
heading your harder opposite that's when
it slows momentum that's when nothing
happens because you want to do it but it
doesn't make sense to do it you really
love it you have to do it but it's no
There's no practical logical safe sense
to do it
you need to get them aligned your heart
needs to say listen to me brain we're
going now help me figure out how to get
there we're jumping now let's figure out
how to make our parachute on the way
down that's how it is big decision with
the heart small ones with the head smart
people come up with really smart reasons
why you can't do something and it's true
there are a million reasons why you will
not win a million reasons but there are
eight reasons why you will and you have
a choice this is an important choice you
have to decide are you going to focus on
the million reasons why you are not
going to win or on the eight why you
will so let's talk about being an
introvert I'm an introvert I still am an
introvert I own my introvertedness that
often doesn't come across you may not
believe me you might see these videos
and think Evan is so extroverted type A
personality I'm not
I I get nervous in big rooms I don't
like hanging out with strangers I never
talk to the people next to me on flights
or the train or anything I don't go up
and say hi and introduce myself I hate
all that stuff I hate small talks I I
have zero need to be around people if
it's just me and my wife I'm happy I
have zero need for contact to fill my my
social
equation whatever you want to call it
I'm introvert I still am but I I use it
as a positive where it used to be a
really strong negative I used to get
into a fight all the time with my agent
and he said the problem with you Evan is
you don't want to be famous it's like
you're right I don't I don't need to be
famous I don't need the spotlight I
don't want the spotlight
and it finally sunk in that in order for
me to get my message out there the more
known I am the more people hear the
message and so how does an introvert
become famous well we'll see join me on
my journey we're on we're in this
together we'll find out together
but the thing that gets me through all
of it is one going in on the strength
and and turning that introvertedness
into not an excuse but into something
that's empowering I think as introverts
we listen better
I just came back from an event in
Florida where somebody at the dinner
table was saying Evan it's really
surprising how well you listen
yeah because that's all that's all I do
I focus on the person I'm talking to I'm
introverted it's not about me talking
it's about you trying to get a result I
want to help you get a result
and so introverts are fantastic
listeners
and so you actually want to help people
make a change you want to help be a
great salesperson you want to help be a
great speaker you have to know your
audience you got to know who you're
talking to you got to be a great
listener I think that counts from being
introverted
and the second thing is having the
passion and the purpose behind what
you're doing gives you the strength and
courage to do things that are scary
getting up on stage and speaking is
scary for me my biggest fear is is
letting people down my biggest fear is
I'm going to disappoint somebody and so
when I go on stage it's always a fear in
the back of my head is that I'm going to
disappoint these people that they're not
going to feel like they got their
money's worth when I did my tour earlier
this year that was my biggest fear is
every four days I'd be taking a new
stage in a new city and I would just let
people down and I got to face that fear
every day every four days why because
the purpose it means something and so
yes you might be introvert yes you might
have a whole bunch of reasons why you
can't win but the people who win look at
your Heroes look at you look at the
people who you love when you look up to
look at who you respect look at who you
want to be be like look at their store
look at where they came from
chances are they came from a worse spot
than what you currently have right now
the opportunities of resources the
connections they had was worse than what
you currently have at your disposal
right now the only difference between
them and most people is they focus on
the eight reasons why they could win and
most people focus on a million reasons
why they're gonna lose you're afraid of
experimenting because you tie yourself
forth to winning instead of trying if
you base your self-worth off how much
you win then you're only going to try
things that you have a good chance of
winning that thus you play small for
life but instead if you base yourself
forth on trying on the effort that
you're putting in you will fail on most
days but you'll end up accomplishing
more than you ever thought was possible
so every time I go to our YouTube event
I'm always being praised by my
thumbnails people always say Evan's got
the best thumbnails go look at his
thumbnails model his thumbnails use them
as an example for the best practice and
I I internally am always saying our
thumbnails suck we need to get better
sure we might be among the best but we
need to get better we could be way
better than we are right now
why have we become the best
because I'm experimenting constantly
most of my tests do not work I use a
tool called tubebuddy shout out
tubebuddy huge fan we've done over 1100
split tests on our thumbnails where we
want one thumbnail against another and
one against another and one against
another trying to beat our best and most
of the experiments don't work they just
don't work I recently ran an experiment
of on my main Channel putting my face on
the thumbnail with the Youtube white
border against Tony Robbins and it
tanked it was like 80 percent worse than
our current thumbnail and that's okay
people don't like my face next to Tony
Romans that that is okay I'm fine with
it I expect to lose I expect everything
I do not to work but I'm willing to test
it to see I just recently came up with
one thumbnail design where I made the
background purple instead of black
purple instead of black and it actually
did better it did significantly better
and so now I'm testing it out on five
more thumbnails to see does the purple
one do better than the black one if that
works out maybe I rolled it out across
the entire Channel but it's very rare
that I find the win
out of the 1100 experiments that we've
done most of them will not work will
never work even from the beginning I'm
thinking it's probably not going to work
but I'm willing to test that's okay even
if the most likely outcome is failure
it's worth the test to see everyone
tells you to think bigger to dream
bigger to 10x your goals to if you had a
million dollars or a billion dollars
what would you do
I think the bigger problem is not that
you can't come up with a bigger vision
for yourself it's the belief that it's
possible that's why I think that lack of
belief is the world's number one problem
for me for for you for all your Heroes
and gurus all of them the lack of belief
in the next thing in your big vision is
the reason why you're not following
through and being consistent on it
especially for Achievers you guys
entrepreneurs you watch this video you
have big Visions you know if we gave you
the challenge of what is your big goal
what is your big Vision what is the life
you want to create we can get lost in
the exercises right and that Clarity is
power right sitting down writing down
your goals and where do you want to
become and where are you going to be in
five years and all of those things can
be great exercises to get you started to
get you thinking and while we're writing
it down here's what happens while you're
writing it down you actually feel that
it's possible
you've let go of the limitations you've
let go of the restrictions you've let go
of your environment and your situation
said this is what I want to create and
in that moment of boldness you feel like
everything is possible
and then what happens very quickly
afterwards maybe it's 10 minutes after
maybe it's an hour after maybe it's the
next day maybe it even lasts a week you
start to look at that list of where
you're going to be and you think wow I
can't I can't do that right does it
sound familiar have you ever set some
giant goal for yourself feeling bold
motivated and then the next day you wake
up I I can't do that I'm crazy I was
crazy it's not even you telling your
your friends or your family your social
media it's you telling yourself that you
suck and you can't do it right that's
the inner game that we need to work on
so how do we start to fix it one
I think it starts with understanding
that the ideas that you come up with
when you're feeling bold powerful
inspired motivated are actually the
right ones for you when you're feeling
bold and you come up with something and
maybe that's because you watched a video
or had a great conversation or read a
book or went to a conference or event
you're for whatever reason you've
stepped outside your current mindset
limitations belief system you've stepped
outside you're you're looking at you
yeah you look at a more confident more
bold version of you
and you come up with an idea that you
want to do that I believe is actually
the best thing for you and then your
head starts talking you down because
someone like you can't do it be safe be
practical there's no way you can
accomplish it you don't have the money
resources education support system
Etc whatever whatever valid you know
these aren't made up excuses these are
valid excuses valid reasons they make
sense otherwise you wouldn't believe
them
but that's your job to still go off and
do that scary thing Step One is when
you're feeling that boldness and you
come up with an idea understand that
that's actually the best you talking
that's actually the thing you have to go
off and do you have to start building
some momentum towards and your brain
will forever try to keep you small
this is the challenge that we're not
consistent because we don't believe that
we can do the things that we say that we
want to do one of the things that really
helped me
was leaning into
the fact that I'm shy and introverted
and afraid to get in front of the camera
and afraid to get on stage and no need
to be famous that's led to actually a
lot of opportunities
[Laughter]
the more I lean in on those things the
more things come to me I remember doing
a speech at Brandon burchard's growth
event and
I wasn't as myself I was more
professional I was more just given
advice great great advice people loved
it and then he invited me back to speak
at his private Mastermind and now this
these groups are paying 30 to 50 000 to
be in that room so now there's higher
pressure you know like the first one the
ticket was gonna be 100 bucks the ticket
to this one is thirty thousand dollars
to fifty thousand dollars like oh my
gosh extra pressure and I just leaned in
on it
I walked up on stage and I I came after
Dean graziosi so Dean spoke and then it
was me and Dean was using the Flipboard
uh you know this is like a paper beside
you and you're you're flipping one page
at a time and I'd never used a Flipboard
in in any of my presentations I've had
PowerPoint in the past or I normally
just get up and talk but I thought okay
I'm gonna try and use the Flipboard and
I didn't know how to use it I I always
felt like I was blocking somebody uh so
I'm hiding behind the Flipboard trying
to write it and it ended up being really
funny and um
Brendan took me aside after and he said
that was the best that was so much
better than you did at in Arizona at my
first event and Arizona was great but
like you need to lean in on your
goofiness you need to lean in on your
shyness you need to lean in on the
things that make you nervous if you're
if you're nervous say you're nervous if
you have anxiety say you have anxiety
um I I've LED with something like that
it's like I'm I'm scared I'm an
introvert I'm shy and I've got my heart
beating like crazy right now standing up
here in front of all you guys that's how
it led my speech something like that
um and so leaning in on that has helped
has helped me it's a lot more real
yeah it's a lot more real so you don't
feel like you have to be fake you can
just lean in on the thing that makes
your heart go crazy like this lean in on
it if you were to make a video to say I
want to tell you my story
now if I go back to the landscaping
company I want to tell you why I do what
I do and normally I hate making videos
and this makes me really anxious and
nervous and I'm scared to do this but
Landscaping is just so important
it's so important to me because and then
you tell the story with the mom wouldn't
you want to hire that person wouldn't
you want to pay more for that person
right so leaning in on your story on the
thing that you're worried that you're
going to get judged for is the way that
you're gonna win books give you access
to mentors who you would never have
access to if you are struggling thinking
I don't have connections I don't know
anybody who's had success I don't have
any good mentors everybody talks about
mentorship and how important it is and I
don't have anybody in my life to help me
books could be that for you
books can be an accumulation of of
sometimes Decades of knowledge
all condensed down into 200 300 400
pages that you get a window into
somebody else's life
and so whatever you don't know yet
whatever you want to learn chances are
it's in a book it's in videos as well I
love YouTube but it can be in books
there's no excuse not anymore for you
not to get access to the information and
be around the people
that can take you to where you want to
go I'm a big believer that you're a
product of your environment you know
think about who you're hanging out with
where you are right now where you spend
your time
what information are you feeding into
your brain the fact that you're here
watching this video is already a step up
is already showcase that you are an
achiever and that you want more in a
life that you you don't want to stay
where you are that you don't want to be
in the same spot think about one year
from today you don't want to still be
where you are right now right you want
growth you want progress you want impact
you want to touch people's lives that's
why you're here
it just needs to be more consistent it
just needs to be more thorough you know
there's a expression of the fastest way
to learn a language is to go to the
country the fastest way to learn
Japanese is to go to Japan
and if you can't actually go to Japan
then you try to make your environment as
much Japanese as possible you watch
Japanese TV you read Japanese books you
go to Japanese restaurants try to order
in Japanese you start hanging out with
Japanese people you take online Japanese
classes you watch Japanese YouTube
channels like you try to be around it as
much as possible and for too many of us
we're not doing as much you know are you
consistent in watching inspective videos
every morning I make them every morning
for you but you're probably not watching
them every morning are you consistent in
your other habits and your other
routines and the books that you're
reading and the content you're consuming
like are you consistent enough and
that's usually the problem
is that you have these moments where
you're bold and you're ambitious and
like I'm tired of this life and I want
to do better and this is the day and so
you have the energy and motivation and
you go off and do the thing but then
tomorrow you wake up and it's just not
there anymore and you don't stay
consistent on the habit
and the only difference between the
people who've had tons of success and
and where you're at right now is that
they just kept doing it
they just stayed consistent on the habit
and so
if you look at reading as an example I
used to read a ton before YouTube came
out before videos I'm a visual learner
I'd much rather watch something than
than read it but
there was no YouTube there were no real
videos to learn from so I started with
books and now I've come back to books a
little bit where I'm I'm trying to read
10 pages a day so the goal is 10 pages a
day and I've been
95 consistent on hitting 10 pages a day
having an
in to win more than you want them to win
with you you want people to win around
you your friends your family your team
your customers the people you interact
with you want them to win as people in
their life in their goals whatever they
want to accomplish you want them to win
more than you want them to win with you
if you can start to adopt that mindset
it really starts to shift how you see
your relationships how you see your
business how do you see the people on
your team and it allows so much more
positive energy to flow in the right
direction for everybody to accomplish
their goals so quick example
I made a video I made a bunch of videos
on Tony Robbins Tony Robbins is one of
the first people that well he was I
guess the first big person who kind of
recognized the work that I was doing and
he put the video I made on him on his
home page on YouTube and got a lot more
views and we made more videos than Tony
Robbins Tony then invites me to go to
his event we did a couple interviews
together he invites me to go and puts me
in you know the awesome seating right up
front and I got a lot of people coming
up to say hey Evan they recognize me I'm
also wearing the hoodie not that I'm a
celebrity but in that kind of world
people would recognize me and they said
you introduced me to Tony Robbins
that they found out about Tony Robbins
or Simon signic or Tom Billy or whoever
threw the content that I'm putting up
and I had a few people who said hey I I
found out about Tony Robbins from you
and I haven't actually gone back and
watched your videos in a while because
I've been so deep in Tony Robbins land
and now I'm here at this event paid
thousands of dollars to be here learning
from Tony
and I don't watch your channel anymore
but thank you for introducing me to Tony
Robbins because that's what I watch now
I'm pumped
I'm excited it's like that's amazing
thank you for telling me now what I
would I love for them to be with me
forever yes of course absolutely but I'm
more happy that you're off winning if
you watch this video and you learn from
Simon sinek and you've never heard of
him before you have and you want to dive
deeper and then you go and you buy all
his books and you subscribe to him on
YouTube and you dive deep into his world
and you don't come back and watch
another video of mine for another 12
months I'm I'm pumped for you I want you
to win as a human as an entrepreneur
more than I want you to subscribe to my
channel and keep watching videos here
it's just a fundamental shift in how you
see relationships I look at the people
on my team I want them all to win as
people more than win with me and I see
everybody that I'm working with as a
parallel path
you and I right now you're watching this
video we're on a parallel path this is a
parallel path that we're we're marching
on together and then at the end of this
video you're going to go off and go do
something else and hopefully productive
and empowering and impactful you're
gonna have a great day come on let's go
believe Nation but you're gonna go off
and do something else you're gonna
you're gonna step out different carmicha
path and go do something else and maybe
you come back on the path or maybe you
go way off and you never come back but
right now you're watching this video
we're on a parallel path you and I
together
I just want to maximize that time
together that while you're on a path
with me that you're going to become
better and that should be your goal with
the people you're around that we have
these parallel paths that we're running
together for a certain amount of time
and maybe that's 10 minutes in a
conversation maybe that's a year of
somebody working with you maybe that's
10 years maybe that's a life partner
that's forever right but you're on these
parallel paths your goal needs to be
while somebody's interacting with you in
person via email through your content
they're with you that they're a better
person because of that interaction with
you
if you can do that if you can just
change the way you see relationships to
do that instead just think about
yourself first and think about them
first and helping them accomplish what
they need to accomplish even if it means
leaving you I've I've recommended people
to courses and programs that are not my
own I've kicked people off of my team
because I was going to hold them back
they wanted to stay here but like you
need to go and do that thing this is too
safe and comfortable for you and I can't
give you the thing that you want
you have to leave and go do that thing
and push them towards it try to get as
close to customers as possible so it's
great to be making it's big it's great
to be creative it's great to be you know
imagineering of where you could go
when you start to solve the problem for
yourself that's a great step one because
there's probably a lot of people who
currently are who you used to be and
seeing how you solved it for yourself
sharing the videos I need the videos for
myself and then I share them and it
helps other people right so I solved the
problem for me first you solve the
problem for you first I know there's
lots of people like you but you need to
start talking to customers you need to
start getting their feedback you need to
start seeing what they interact with and
that can help guide a lot of your future
product or service creation you need to
get out of just sitting by yourself on
your couch researching and into actually
talking to people so a quick example
from my channel
the whole top 10 rules for Success thing
came because I just made one video on
Kanye West that's why he's you know on
the wall behind me made one video on him
and then people started requesting more
hey can you do Dame Dash hey can you do
Jay-Z hey can you do Jeff Bezos hey can
you do Steve Jobs hey can you do these
people and
it's like well that's a cool idea sure
why not I could do that I never thought
of it as being a whole series I just was
wanted to give a tribute to Kanye West
and it was a one-off video
and then in the videos that people were
suggesting can you do this person this
person this person this person I still
get final say we ended up having over 2
000 different requests for people to
profile I still get final sales to who
we profile
because I have to feel connected to the
message and when I'm pulling out the
content if we're doing Kanye West or
Steve Jobs is always something positive
it's always through the lens of belief
because that's what I want to put out I
don't want to put out Kanye West's
biggest attacks or insults or negativity
I want to put out negativity in the
world I could easily done top 10 top 10
Kanye West stupidest things you've ever
done I'm not interested in putting that
out
so it's that combination of what people
are asking for hey can you do this can
you do that can you do this plus what I
love doing right what I want to put my
stake in the ground to say I made this
right this is the contribution that I'm
trying to make to the world back to the
entrepreneur success formula right what
you love doing with what brings value to
other people so how to figure out what
brings value to other people you have to
get as close to the customer as possible
understand their business understand
what they're going through understand
their mindset you solving the problem
for yourself is a good first step and
then going into okay what are you
struggling with take some kind of
immediate action
most people's immediate action is
research
planning that's not enough immediate
action is doing you have to do something
and you don't know where to start this
is the next thing yeah I don't know
where to start I want to start a YouTube
channel I don't know where to start you
start by pulling out your phone and
making a video I'm in my car
on my phone making a video
you can too
it's not worrying about it being perfect
it's expecting to suck and just start
just create
I call them supercent differences for
like what's the first two percent on
your idea we plan to get to 100 instead
of just going and doing something on the
first two percent
whatever that big idea is
start to teach yourself that your ideas
are amazing the ideas of Flow To You are
good
they're good for you they're good for
your family they're good for your
community they're good for the world
they're good and you have a duty to
start doing something towards them start
to train yourself on this recently I
wanted to learn about nfts and
cryptocurrency and I've I've dabbled and
learned a little bit but I just decided
I'm gonna I'm gonna figure this out
and last week on Friday I spent the day
learning it and I had all sorts of
obstacles thrown in my way I couldn't
get money out of my bank account because
my bank blocked cryptocurrency purchases
my Visa blocked cryptocurrency purchases
there's a whole bunch of restrictions as
a Canadian to buy from the different
exchanges all sorts of problems all sort
and you know what like one problem after
another after another my my U.S bank
account like well I've got a US account
with TD so I'm gonna go to my us account
no problem
the TD was closed the online banking had
a had a update that their website
crashed like oh my gosh it's like
non-stop but we figured it out built
some momentum started taking some kind
of action
and makes a huge huge huge huge
difference because while you're feeling
the Bold energy if you wait till
tomorrow you won't feel the energy
anymore you can have the perfect plan
but tomorrow you don't have the same
mindset and so you won't execute the
plan embrace the and most people are
thinking or most people are thinking do
I do this or doing this do I do this
business or do this business if you
think about your passions and your
interests right what do you love doing
what's your heart-centered thing that
you could do all day you probably have a
couple things and you feel like you have
to pick this is the mistake people feel
like you have to pick you don't have to
pick the actual selection is in doing
both of those things combined a lot of
people have said some amazing things of
me it's very humbling I think of Ed
mylett and garyvee where garyvee called
me the DJ that likes to watch so much
content and then spin it to inspire
people and Ed mylett said that I'm the
modern day Napoleon Hill Napoleon Hill
is the biggest influence of all time
personal development and I'm the modern
day Napoleon Hill first off that's
extremely humbling but why are they
saying that this is how I'm unique
because I love consuming all of this
stuff and I love spinning it and mixing
it up as well as adding my own message
to things this is how I'm Different
there's a lot of people who are just
sharing their message and there's a lot
of people who are also mixing things
together but there's nobody who's really
mixing things together and sharing their
own message right so instead of looking
at those two things as different right
like I have to pick I got to pick this
or this like I'm going to combine them
and that's how I'm going to be unique so
think about your different interests
what do you love doing what are what are
your top two three things that you can
get lost in and they feel completely
different
your Genius is going to be in actually
mixing those things together in a way
that's never been done before and then
usually not to bring value to people
stop thinking or and instead embrace the
end the trick to getting yourself into
action mode is to trigger yourself for
Success triggering yourself for Success
means you've taken the decision making
out of it that as soon as you come up
with an idea you have trained Yourself
by default into action mode you see your
brain will always talk you down from
things because it's trying to keep you
safe and it only understands a world
that currently exists that is logical
and practical until you learn to trigger
yourself for Success you will constantly
doubt your thoughts your ideas and your
actions this video is gonna help so
today I want to talk about this bag
right here a lot of you leave comments
so newer fans of the channel say why is
Doritos sponsoring your videos Evan why
don't you have a healthier sponsor don't
you know what bad Doritos does to your
body you should be promoting healthy
living
Doritos is not a sponsor guys this is
this is triggering me for Success every
single day and this isn't just some tiny
bag it looks small looking back here but
let me bring this up look at that this
is right next to my face look at how big
that baggage readers is I have a
strategy
and it's a weird strategy so maybe
you'll love it maybe you won't but I
have a strategy called Damn the Doritos
I look at this bag so I'm sitting this
is how I'm working right I'm not sitting
I'm standing I'm standing on a
trampoline this is my workspace right
now right I'm standing here I'm working
in the corner of my eye I got Steve Jobs
up here and I got I got this giant bag
of Doritos all I want to do is eat this
bag all day long I want to destroy this
bag of Doritos look at that giant ship
oh
I'm gonna start drooling soon I love it
I want to eat that all day long
this bag is here as a reminder of how
great I am this is the mental
conversation inside my head Evan you're
awesome you're awesome for not eating
those Doritos every day and I want it as
a reminder people say it doesn't take a
lot of willpower
no it it builds for me at least builds
the willpower builds my strength every
time I see that bag of Doritos makes me
feel better about myself that I'm not
eating it and I have the strength to
keep going and so why I have that here
is when you're on a diet right this is
how it began when you're on a diet your
friends your family the experts will say
get rid of all the junk food from your
house get rid of it all because
otherwise you'll be tempted and then
you're gonna eat it and then you're
gonna ruin your diet I think that is
actually teaching yourself that you suck
you're teaching yourself I'm a weird
duck you're teaching yourself that you
are not strong enough to be around the
thing and so I need to get it out of my
environment the only way that I can
stick to this thing is if this other
stuff is nowhere close to me I think
you're telling yourself that you suck I
think it's a big crutch and just like
when you break your leg you have a
crutch your ultimate goal is to not have
a crutches to walk it's to run is to be
stronger than before right and so as a
step one maybe it's good right it's a
step one okay fine you broke your leg
you have a crutch you want to get on a
diet you're addicted to junk food get
out of the house awesome but as soon as
you go on vacation as soon as you go to
an office party as soon as you go to the
New Year's any kind of party you're
going to destroy the food because you've
trained yourself every day that you suck
that you're not capable I think you're a
genius I think you're stronger than you
think and so I tested it first with
myself and I thought you know what
Doritos are my Nemesis right I love
Doritos
oh my gosh she's looking at that bag so
I went to Costco and bought the giant
sized bag of Doritos I said I'm going to
put this on my desk all day long because
damn the Doritos because the Doritos are
stronger than me I don't think so right
I'm Evan Carmichael and same thing for
you
that thing that is holding you that's
that's stronger than you I don't think
so remember who you are remember how
strong you are and that's what this is
here for and it's been awesome to see
people now take this up a friend of the
channel uh LeRon was trying to get off
of sugar and he has a coffee cup with a
saucer and he drinks his morning coffee
and he put two packets of sugar on the
saucer right next to the coffee so he
pourses coffee has the sugar right next
to it and he just starts drinking it and
puts it down and looks at the sugar
packs and then just drinks the coffee
again and puts it down looks at the
sugar pack and his wife thinks he's
crazy and he's a little crazy too you
got to be a little bit weird duck but
but I think this is actually how you
build your strength
Mark Drake another friend of the channel
is addicted to the peak friends cookies
you know the ones that have the the red
on the inside and the cream in the
middle those are among my favorites too
and so his CEO when he heard this went
out and bought all these boxes of peak
frames and put it on Mark's desk and he
opened it up and this is one of my
favorite things to do when whenever I'm
around Doritos or something I really
love to to eat not just say oh put that
away from me don't be around me I can't
have that and not just look at it I want
to smell it
so Mark took these cookies brought it
right up here Peak free cookies right up
here
oh and you can just see the Joy on his
face Jess as he's bringing back memories
and just what those cookies are gonna
taste like when they enter his stomach
and just um goodness everywhere right
the smile on his face maybe a little bit
of drool coming out you just oh
and then put the cookies down and walk
away
and how great that makes you feel as a
human to say here's one of my biggest
weaknesses of all time Bring It
I own you put it down and walk away
right I think that's how you actually
build strength by doing those difficult
things by triggering yourself for
Success every time I see the Doritos bag
I feel better about myself I feel
stronger about myself and I want you to
do the same thing if any of you are
gonna take on that kind of challenge I
want to hear you I want to follow you I
want to I want to see how your journey
is going because it's gonna be one of
the biggest most important life-changing
decisions that you embark on making
money is about solving problems that's
the core of business someone has a
problem you see a solution they pay you
to solve it if you're not making money
it's because you haven't solved a big
enough problem yeah
so let's use my YouTube channels as an
example now we got so many YouTube
channels it's crazy
I saw a problem I saw a need right I
wanted visual content I wanted to learn
from successful entrepreneurs and I
wanted it done in a visual way I used to
read books a lot because books was the
only way that I was able to get this
information I didn't have mentors to
teach me about business right I had my
parents who were amazing who taught me
how to be a human but didn't have any
face-to-face mentors that I can go to so
I went the books but I'm a visual
learner I'd much rather see it I get a
lot more by seeing Simon talk about a
message than by reading his book I just
do it's how I learned and I think a lot
of people are visual Learners and so
it's why I started my YouTube channel
I started showcasing successful stories
and started sharing my stories while in
the process and has been that Duality
from the beginning of saying here's what
you can learn from successful people and
here's my message as well so DJ plus
thought leader mixed together and here
we go and and we've had success because
it solves the problem because a lot of
you have the same problem my problem is
your problem you want more success
around you you want to be surrounded by
these people just like I did and instead
of you having to watch 40 hours of Simon
Sina content to find the best and wish
it together I do it for you I actually
didn't want to even have a YouTube
channel I didn't want to do this I wish
you did this if one of you did this I
would just subscribe be great be free
here we go amazing it was it didn't
exist it wasn't out there so I did it
and that's the process you could scratch
your own itch you could you can see what
problems other people have but success
in business comes from solving other
people's problems you subscribe to this
channel because you like the content
because hopefully hopefully like the
content it adds value to your life it
solves a problem it sets you up for the
day that's why I have this morning
espresso series of five times a week
Monday to Friday set you up for the day
give you the shot of energy motivation
plus ideas to help you go off and build
your business this is the problem that I
solve what's the big problem that you
solve everything that you want out of
life is on the other side of your
biggest fears you want something more
you know you're capable of something
more you'll come up with a great reason
why you can't do that something more but
really you're just afraid if you want a
breakthrough if you want that dream life
you need to change the way you think
about fear or it will handicap you for
the rest of your life so my biggest fear
is disappointing people
I'm afraid that whatever I'm gonna do I
might disappoint somebody and that keeps
me plain small and so whenever I can
recognize it then I have to go all in
and do it just to show myself because it
allows you to play on a bigger stage
every time and that big fear you have is
still there it doesn't go away You're
Just capable of slaying a bigger dragon
each time so what used to count as
disappointed people in my fear of
disappointing people might have been
going to a coffee meeting and helping an
entrepreneur I remember one time super
clearly that I was booking a meme with
an entrepreneur and I was so worried
that I was going to disappoint her that
I was hoping that she would cancel and
the story told myself was I'm too busy I
got all the stuff to do you know the the
realistic reasons that you can convince
yourself right they weren't stupid
reasons they're realistic but deep down
was I'm just afraid I'm afraid that
she's gonna show up and I'm not gonna
give her value it's a deep fear
and then once I went to go meet her it
was amazing I remember sitting in my car
I was like wow like an hour and a half
ago I I was hoping that she was gonna
cancel on me and this is the greatest
thing of all time right your biggest
fears
prevent you from living the life that
you want and so I'm afraid of
disappointing people most of the time
you can't catch it I think we place them
all by default I think your greatest
fear owns you and is giving you tons of
logical reasons why I can't do that
thing but whenever you catch it whenever
you do watch a catch and say I think
this is just my fear talking
that means it's go time that means you
have to do it just to teach yourself
that you're able to conquer it and move
to a greater level of success most
focused on the pro the problem instead
of the solution and that is why they
failed I like to say that there are a
million reasons why your ideas will
never work out and only eight why they
will either way you're right so it's
better to focus on the eight Your Heroes
the people that you look up to the
people that you love and want to be like
right Your Heroes all succeeded with
less than what you currently have right
now if they can all do it so can you the
only thing in your way are your excuses
so one of the things that I love most
about both my wife and my team is that
they're always willing to find the way
one of the things that Nina loves most
about herself I had her fill out this
form maybe two years ago of like what do
you love most about yourself and at the
top was she's a fast learner she loves
learning new things she loves taking on
new challenges and I love that I love
that about her and I love that in people
I think you should be a fast learner I
think you should love learning I think
you should always be taking on New
Opportunities right now my YouTube
channel I've split up my channel into 80
or nine different channels and then just
recently I split them up again where we
launched a top 10 Channel just for the
top 10 videos so the top 10 videos
aren't on my main Channel anymore and uh
then we're doing an everything Channel
where if you just want all the content
it's all on one spot so it's chaos it's
crazy my whole team has to be
restructured and everybody's taking on
new projects and responsibilities and we
were supposed to have a one month
transition phase to do it
that was a recommendation that was that
was the aggressive recommendation this
is have a one month transition period
and for me one month just as death it's
just death I mean I said okay great one
month but then as I'm into it on the
Tuesday of like the first week like guys
we need to launch like this weekend
we need to launch this weekend let's go
right and and there's so many reasons
why it's not gonna work and there's so
many problems and yes we're gonna make
so many mistakes and people aren't
trained properly and there's more work
and we need to you know we figure out
who wants to do what and how so many
issues awesome let's go
I think about Rey for example on my team
who has been doing all these thumbnails
so I have I have a set design for my top
10 rules thumbnails that people love and
it's it's been going like that for years
and I've always been on my team to say I
don't care that everybody thinks their
thumbnails are great they can be better
how do we make them better and so
finally finally after years of testing
we finally found the format that would
win that would that would beat our
original thumbnails and there's minor
differences we zoom in on the face we
got rid of the second logo make the text
bigger minor differences and then Rey
has been going back and updating split
tests doing against their old videos we
have 13 1400 different split tests on my
videos it's crazy I think I split test
more than anybody on YouTube so he's
going back and updating all the old
thumbnails
and trying to prove a winner each time
and he's maybe I don't know halfway
through he's like think about how many
videos we have on the channel we've got
6 000 videos a lot of them are our top
tens
now with this change I found a new
format
we found a new format a new thumbnail
different color scheme different texts
different pictures
different logo new thumbnail format and
we found that it's working and so I said
Ray
I know you just changed all the
thumbnails
we gotta do it again he's like this is
so exciting let's go I love those guys
so much right where most people what are
they they're gonna complain they're
gonna say I just did all this work on
this other thing right
you don't want to be around people like
that and you definitely don't want to be
that for too many people the problem is
for so many people that's you that's not
even people around you that's you you're
thinking about all the sunk costs that
you put into something you're thinking
about invested so much into this thing
and and now you want me to shift
everything
yep
you need to be on the yep side now you
need to adopt that kind of mindset that
kind of personality that just because I
worked before it doesn't mean it's going
to keep working you find something new
it's better let's go this is what the
whole game is about the reason why you
are not chasing your big dream is
because you are afraid that is going to
fail you're afraid that it's not gonna
work and what people will say about you
and what you will think about yourself
but what's the alternative it's sitting
on your idea for years never taking your
shot because you're afraid and living
the rest of your life in regret knowing
that you had an opportunity but were too
afraid to take it the way to not have
regrets is to be always taking action to
as soon as you get an idea go do
something about it I had a great podcast
with my friend Mark driger uh a couple
weeks ago a month ago or so where he was
asking me about regret and I used to
always tell this story of imagine you
have a hangnail how much that hurts and
it's all you can think about when you
have a hangnail but if somebody punches
you in the arm you don't feel the
hangnail anymore because you this hurts
more right you focus on what hurts more
and suddenly this one doesn't hurt as
much that's how I would use regret I
would always think about whatever pain
that I'm in right now this thing that I
want to do that I'm afraid I would
imagine that this thing is going to be
the best thing of all time that this
video I'm gonna make this feature I'm
gonna give this client I'm going to make
is gonna be the best of all time and if
I don't do it I'm going to regret it for
the rest of my life for decades I'm
gonna regret not taking action and so
the pain of doing the thing is the Hang
nail and the future pain of regret for
decades is the punch to the arm and so
it inflicts so much pain on me that then
I have to go off and do that thing and I
use that for
over a decade
over a decade that's the lens through
which I've made decisions inside the
world
but for the past two years I haven't
done that at all I haven't talked about
it I haven't done it for myself because
I talk about the things that I live
and I'm thinking why why don't I do that
anymore why don't I use future regret to
fuel me
and I found this because I'm always
taking action because as soon as I get
an idea I do something and so I don't
judge the idea I don't say why me I
don't Ponder on the idea I don't I don't
just default to strategizing the
thinking I don't think why did I come up
with this why am I thinking about this I
just do it you get an idea you go off
and do it and that's been my mindset for
the past year and a half two years and
as a result the Breakthrough was you
don't live with regret
if you're always taking action on the
ideas that you have you don't live with
regret you might regret some of the
things you end up doing but most of the
things that you regretting other things
done as the action's undone not undone
not taken the action is not taken you
don't regret the things that you did you
get the things that you didn't do that's
most people right there may be a couple
things that you regret that you did but
for the most part it's the things that
you are too afraid to do that you regret
for the rest of your life and so if
you're constantly doing if you're
constantly taking action if you're
always jumping then you don't have
regrets and it's been an interesting way
that I announced to the world and
hopefully you can learn from as soon as
you get an idea you go off and you do
something you do that you won't have any
regrets
[Music]
oh I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there and we're stuck and this was me
too I was stuck it took me forever to
get started and I thought I had to have
the perfect cameraman my first video if
you go back and watch it on my channel I
had my friend come and film